we are on this is the new hampshire
house election law committee today is
friday we have some public hearings and
then we're going to be exacting some
bills because we have deadlines coming
up and before we begin that official
business i'd like you all to join me in
a pledge of allegiance
i pledge allegiance to the part of the
united states of america and to the
republic for which it stands one nation
under god indivisible with liberty and
justice for all
thank you very much everybody the first
bill scheduled for public hearing this
morning at 10 o'clock and my apologies
to the prime sponsor for starting late
is sb 348 and with us to introduce 348
is the prime sponsor senator gray
welcome back to election lot senator
gray a former home of senator gray
ah yes yes
my name is james gray i represent senate
district six
and my legislative career on committee
started in this room
and
so you know i'm familiar with election
law i was a moderator for many many
years in rochester
uh
this bill here
one of the most confusing things for
people
is
finance for campaigns
in fact
the secretary
excuse me the attorney general's office
has a piece of paper
that they say well this is what it
really means the statute and we're not
doing the right thing if we have to have
another piece of paper from another
person that says this is what it really
means
and they had a table there
so i went down to ols and i said
i want you to put the table in
well i said well wait we don't have any
tables in any part of the statute
anywhere
i said i don't care i want the table in
okay
so
i guess from my request and other
requests that they've had both now and
in the past
they think that they have figured a way
to get a table in
and that is the the genesis of what you
see in this bill
as amended by the senate is two tables
okay we had rousing discussion about
what's in there
we thought that last year that we had
gotten it down so that was uh
pre-primary and primary expenses and
then a second category for uh general
election expenses the attorney general
says nah you didn't get there
um you still have the three categories
so the table reflects the first table
that you see pretty much reflects what's
in statute right now about the different
things
the second table
in the the senate bill is amended
uh actually is a
reduction in that first line that you
have in the table
uh the rest of it says unlimited
unlimited and unlimited
well the attorney general says that the
actual statutes that we have in place
all of those lines would be unlimited
and i said well that goes a little too
far for me
i had it even smaller and if you look
back at the bill's history you will see
where i suggested other things
but
you know like
many of the house members
i'm very frugal in what i spend on my
campaign
and i spend a lot a lot less than a lot
of other senators
uh on their campaign so you know
the problem that you get into is when
you're transferring money at the end of
your tenure or
when you lose or whatever and you want
to pass that money on to someone else
you can pass it on to a charitable
organization you can pass it on to
another campaign campaign committee and
that's what
the reason why some of those numbers
especially
the the middle row
in the amended version which was
quite a bit less than that when the bill
started out
went to unlimited because
if somebody's already donated that money
for
campaign expenses
then it is certainly reasonable that
that money continued to be used for
campaign expenses
for
especially for the the candidate in the
same district but again that's all fair
game for you guys
uh the the main thrust of this bill is
to make it
so that a person who gets that
picks up that statute can understand
what the limits are
understand the difference between
candidates candidate committees advocacy
organizations what happens to
a
union what happens to
partnerships what happens to all of that
stuff
we did put in special provision
that
that unions etc would be able to form a
political action
committee of their own and to be able to
use segregated funds for that purpose
which matches federal law so
i believe it's a great bill you know
certainly i'd like to see a 20-0 vote
out of here or whatever your your
current
committee membership is
and
i'll shut up now and listen to you
questions from committee members for
senator gray
i'm not seeing any you've made it very
clear apparently so thank you very much
for joining us this morning senator gray
um we do have someone who has signed up
to speak on this bill
uh olivia zink
welcome
to the senate portion of our year
good morning and for the record my name
is olivia zink executive director for
open democracy action
and i live in the city of franklin
the reason i signed up to oppose this
bill today
is one because it's under the prohibited
political contributions part of the law
so if senator gray explained that these
are in statute right now it should be in
the statute part of the law not
prohibited and i get that there's a
double negative
in line 17 but then when you say it's
unlimited it really throws me off so
you're limited to unlimited
um that should be in the regular part of
the law and not prohibited political
contributions section of the law
and i and i will just speak that i i do
believe unlimited political spending um
does not protect our democracy um and
further transparency in our elections so
i think it's really important that we
have good standards and that our
campaign finance laws
provide the clarifications they need but
by putting this under the prohibition
and creating these double negatives in
statute i think create uh further
confusion
thank you
thank you very much i'm trying to think
what the double negative means to the
term unlimited
because it's prohibited you're
prohibited to be unlimited but isn't a
contribution an amount by definition so
it's never unlimited
i mean you're causing me to think about
the double negative you can never not
you will always be on
not unlimited regardless of the amounts
i don't know
yeah well if you're prohibiting
something that's unlimited right how are
you right how are you making a
prohibition on something that's
unlimited that's the confusion that i
think this causes
well i think that the answer is it can
be any amount but you're right it does
seem a little confusing
any
other questions for olivia's ape
see none thank you very much
is there anybody else here who wants to
speak on sb 348
i'm
come on down welcome to the committee on
our senate session of our
year here
thank you for
recognizing me on a moment's notice you
will have to do a pin card and i know
you know that procedure yes ma'am all
right thank you
i take no position i need you to
identify yourself yeah i'm sorry bob
perry town of strafford
served on this committee a number of
years ago for seven years
again i take no position on the bill but
i would like to stress
my angst at
the word unlimited
when i see the word unlimited connected
to the words campaign contributions i
worry
there is much concentrated wealth in
america and we know in so many instances
wealth begets wealth
this week we learned that elon musk
bought 9.2 percent of twitter
according to forbes he is the world's
richest person with a wealth of 275
billion dollars
buying a controlling interest in twitter
cost him a mere 2.9 billion
one person
twitter reaches 330 million people with
roughly 206 million
monetized daily users
for someone on a mission which musk
seems to be he has a sizable megaphone
outsizing every voice
in this room times millions
he admits he bought it not only to
assert his position among the wealthy
who own media giants
but to make changes at twitter likely
code for increasing profitability
at his now personal mouthpiece
i can imagine he will use controversy to
increase profits
i don't have to imagine it
he has already stirred controversy
according to reporting from politico
magazine
mr perry i appreciate your experience
and your position but i really am going
to ask you to focus in on this bill
and not the motives of elon musk in
buying shares of twitter
my point madam chair is that if anyone
has the ability to buy an election
it's elon musk representative perry
you're going to have to speak to the
bill because i think every member on
this committee can point out a number of
other people under that same logic that
could buy elections so let's continue
with focusing on the bill
some people believe more money and more
speech is good
that it will lead to an expansion of
ideas upon which to build a more perfect
union
to those i refer to the present
political environment of misinformation
disinformation outright lies and coming
up
i'm going to ask you to conclude now i
have never done that in a hearing but we
are not going to become a platform for
agenda i want comment on the bill and if
you're not next statement is not related
to the bill
in regards to what you would like us to
do with the portion of the bill that you
find objectionable i'm going to thank
you for your testimony and close the
public hearing
the bottom line is
with the words unlimited in this
amendment i hope we can begin to make
changes
by eliminating the word unlimited
with respect to campaign contributions
thank you thank you input to what could
be an amendment does anybody have any
questions for mr perry
thank you
is there anybody else here who would
like to speak to
sb 348 and mr perry if you can give me
that pink card that would be great
seeing none i'm going to close the
public hearing on 3 48 and we are in
recess for a few minutes until 10 30
when we will have a hearing on 4 25 and
the prime sponsor is here if it wasn't
for our clerk i would just go right into
it but i will wait till 10 30. we are in
recess thank you
all right
so let's keep
it actually reduces
thank you
am i telling her the truth
to be able to officially
that
for sure
the easier it is
is
idea
unions
if you go back to the introduced
uh
bit
uh it didn't say
on the second table
there's the second table right now
but anyways
okay
i
a lot of
encouraging
i
foreign
all right
christina are we on yeah all right we
are rolling everybody this is the new
hampshire house election law committee
we are back in session on this friday
april 8th it is 10 30 somewhere
and with us to introduce house bill 425
is the prime sponsor senator gray
welcome back this morning uh thank you
my name for the record is james gray i'm
a senator from district six which starts
in rochester goes up route 11
until alton barnes said in government
um
portal
uh this is an idea that uh
i think it's time has come
but it has one thing that
you were going to find that it has a
a very healthy price tag
and the reason for that price tag is
that
we're the only ones
right now that are trying to do this
that if other departments other
[Music]
divisions of state government
come into this and use that portal uh
that that price tag will be reduced and
reduced and reduced
uh certain things that you could do
uh for the dmv certain things that you
could do for
your taxes
combining that into the portal things
that you can do for
other functions in state government
what is my vision
my vision
as chair of the senate election law
is that
a citizen
there's never a question of can they
vote
and the question just becomes where can
they vote
so
through the portal
we want to use information that's out
there
probably this isn't secure information
anymore but i have a brother
who was
here with his then girlfriend later his
wife
that got married in new hampshire in
and my brother and sister stood up for
him at the city hall in dover okay
the city clerk has information they can
go into the vital records and look at
that marriage certificate and if
somebody can go in and tell me what my
brother and my sister's first name is
i'm pretty sure that that is somebody
that
you know has the right to go vote
but this other thing's out there
you send people a tax bill
tax bill's got an account number on it
they can tell me what that account
number is see that's pretty good
information but that's not the kind of
information the portal uses the portal
uses a service
the way i understand it and the i.t
department can correct me if i'm wrong
but there are services out there you
know when you go into the bank and you
say oh i forgot my password and they ask
you who your grandfather's mother's
maiden name is
and they ask you here's three addresses
please pick the one
that was associated with you they give
you a list of phone numbers and say okay
which one of these
that information is in a database out
there
and it's the same one or run by the
credit card companies the way i've been
told
may be true not true but i'll let you
figure it out
and all that information isn't a big
database out there and you know what
because of all these other data
breaches you know for social security
number and other things they have looked
for these other things
to be able to prove identity and prove
who you are
and that's where i'm trying to get to
that in every
polling place
they will have internet access and they
will be able to log in and say okay
we know this about you
right now on the current registration
form we ask for place of birth date of
birth we ask for the driver's license
and if you don't have the driver's
license please give me the last four
digits to your social security number
we also know if they were registered in
the state in another location
part of this you'll actually see
when you look at the 418 that's going to
come in front of you or you look at the
amendment that was never introduced over
in the senate for ways that that could
happen
but the thing is identity we need
you know in the statute right now it
says
first of all you have to establish
identity so that the records you present
for citizenship domicile
etc and age
we know that they apply to you
okay so
this comes with a price tag and the
price tag is a lot more than what i
wanted it to be
a lot more
but again that cost
as other departments as other
functions on the state
get onto this program it'll be cut in
half it'll be cut into the third it'll
be cut into a fourth it'll be cut in
whatever number
of others
and new hampshire is pope
it is poised on that precipice where we
need to start into this digital age
we've got people out there you know i
look at the polling place and i see a
line at the registration table
okay if there was an app
the person in line could start typing in
the information that's required and it's
not all that much information
that by the time they get there hit the
button the person says well i got this
number from the portal
the person goes in and check yep um yep
we've got all the stuff we need have one
form they write the number up at the top
they sign it show you their id and they
walk out registered
okay
those are my visions
but you got to take small steps
and one of those steps is this portal
it's expensive
yep
we're right up front about it it's
expensive
and with that
i hope that you'll look kindly on this
bill
again i'd like to see the 20-0 but you
know i'm i'm willing to discuss this
with anybody who wants to vote against
it and try to convince you
so
thank you madam chair
thank you senator gray any questions for
senator gray
representative terosian
thank you madam chair thank you thank
you senator for taking the question so
as i understand this legislation it
would um
would get the ball rolling with setting
this portal up uh in regards to towns
and municipalities um
would they have a choice to use it and
not use it or would they have to
all be
enrolled in this once it's complete the
portal as it's described in this bill
would be for the collection of
information to change party affiliation
to change name because you got married
to change address because you've moved
to change it change and change and right
now that would have an interface the my
vision is have an interface with the
existing
computer
that we have and a notification would go
to
the supervisor of the checklist and the
clerk and that they would take the
additional actions that was needed to
accomplish the change
i think i forgot to mention party
affiliation
if somebody wanted to change that but
the this portal would not be able to do
anything by itself
it would mean that that's the way you
could notify
the two groups the clerk's office and
the
supervisor of the checklist and then
they would take it from there
let's say a change of name because you
got married
certainly the
city clerk could go into vital records
if they were married in new hampshire
and be able to look in there and say yup
and probably accept the
you know just the information that was
on that form
but again that's all
up to the secretary of state and the
clerks and the supervisors of the
checklist who are already trained in
what they need for information
further questions from committee members
representative prudhomme o'brien
thank you madam chair
i'm looking at the expenditures on this
and
it just keeps going up and up
why is that and do you think that trend
would continue
would it continue to go up and double
each year and
well
part of what i've talked about is
this would be a subscription service
okay
that uh the person that turns 18 this
year probably doesn't have a lot of
credit card banking or other information
that's in that portal and so you know
two years from now
there will be additional information so
part of it is a subscription thing but
for the
real details on that
they should be addressed to
commissioner goulet
and commissioner goulet would be
commissioner of what
ig
thank you
further questions from committee members
representative
thank you madam chair thank you senator
um could i just follow up and represent
your answer to representative prudent
o'brien
would this election portal have my
credit card information
this
database would have
access to data
that was
in the subscription service that they
had
so it would not contain any information
um that is not uh either public record
or whatever
you have a follow-up follow-up chair um
how many other states use this a system
like this or the system that you're
imagining
if the question is not
that the state government
uses that system which is a thing i
don't know
but
like the city of rochester
for their economic development group
to be able to say
gee
this data says that
we need a clothing store over here uh
gee this data says that a shoe store
will do over there
it's all the same
kind of data that you've got so
i wouldn't hesitate to say that that
data is being used in
every state and in quite a few
municipalities within the state but i
couldn't tell you that any of it is
state-sanctioned
we have one more small follow-up
would you be
um
would you welcome a a you know a study
group to to flesh out this idea or
are you convinced that it should be
legislated at this point in time
uh would i welcome a study group the
answer that is when you're the sponsor
of a bill is always no
i mean the reason the reason i put the
bill in is because
i think it's something that the time has
come we have in the senate as some of
the people behind me probably will
testify
that it's an idea that we've talked
about
covid probably got in the way
but uh
you know
mrs tentarelli even in some of her other
statements she told me i was her best
friend friend forever about three years
ago yeah you know because i am we try to
not hold anybody to prior statements
before they come in this room senator
gray it just causes all sorts of
problems we have we have that love-hate
relationship
we say no more that's fine let's move on
i mean this bill is your
bill now okay it is in your committee
you have control of it
okay all right thank you representative
bergeron yes thank you this is a very
simple question i think senator gray
were you aware that
new hampshire cities and towns and the
department of vital records already use
a service that you've described for
vital check if someone wants to order a
vital record they have to prove their
identity and vital check which is a
private corporation uses that type of
service there'll be four or five
questions that are generated using
credit reports and other public records
and the person has to answer those
questions correctly in order to have
access to be able to order a birth
certificate because here in new
hampshire those records are confidential
and this is how they establish the
identity of the person
that wants to access the record i will
certainly uh inform
uh
commissioner goulet of your statement
and make sure he's got your phone number
thank you
any further questions for senator gray
representative hamer
hi senator gray um
is there a you mentioned about changing
your party affiliation
is there a time limit on that
prior to the election
uh that's kind of
not really part of this bill but
certainly there is
is that uh traditionally like in a
general election uh the period for being
able to change your party affiliation
stops at the
period of time when you can sign up as a
candidate uh so that there isn't people
that are swapping
in and out of parties during that time
uh and trying to use that as a way to
get an advantage
when they see somebody that's not signed
up
for a particular political party in a an
office they want uh in
i'm told that in the far past they used
to
go down register for that party put
their name on the ballot and that's
prohibited now
thank you
further questions from committee
it appears the members have no more
questions for you senator gray thank you
for joining us this morning introducing
the bill
also signed up to speak on 425 i'm going
to recognize liz tentarelli next unless
she forgets what senator gray expects
her to say
thank you madam chair my name is liz
tentarelli i'm president of the league
of women voters of new hampshire
and when i first became aware of this
bill it was as an amendment
to i think it was a proposed uh
automatic voter registration bill that
you know as you can imagine didn't go
anywhere and that was two years ago and
so i was testifying in support of that
on the theory that people ought to be
able to register they can go to the dmv
and get their driver's license and maybe
there's a way to register at the same
time
and then senator gray kind of waved
these papers at me and said look at this
and i embarrassed myself in the public
hearing by saying you're my bff now
so he's quite right in this story
while it's not an automatic voter
registration bill
it does allow people to start the voter
registration process online
they already have information in the
system
and it also allows them to change
addresses my grandson at that time was
moving from between jobs from college to
job to next job and changing apartments
in another state and he was able to do
all those address changes online so that
he could continue voting
and i believe that this system
as it was described then would would be
an advantage to voters you you know we
can all
change our party affiliation back to
undeclared as we leave the polling place
and sometimes that's confusing and
people forget to do it this would allow
someone to do that online later so i see
this bill as a real boon uh for voters
for convenience
and so i testified when this bill was in
the hou and the senate a few weeks ago
and said it's probably the only time
that i've been able to testify
in support of a bill that had all the
sponsors that were on the committee
bipartisan support sitting there
and then it got voted out of committee
unanimously ought to pass so
that was a joyous day for me and i just
wanted to encourage you to do the same
thing thank you
thank you any questions for ms
genterelli
seeing that thank you for being with us
this morning also signed up to speak we
are on
sb425 is michael o'brien
thank you madam chairman of the
committee my name is michael o'brien
here on behalf of america votes i'm here
in support of the election information
portal
um for many of the reasons that uh
listing charlie just expressed to you
all but also think about it in a
slightly different context i think you
know in a very short amount of time
we're about to spend a lot of time
talking about
uh voter registration and that process
and one of the advantages to the portal
um is that if folks are able to do this
before they get to election day uh it
lessens the number of folks who will
have to make these changes on election
day
oftentimes when we see affidavits filled
out if you talk to moderators and clerks
around the state it's because the person
has moved either out of ward
or into a new town and doesn't have the
necessary documentation with them and so
then they get put onto this affidavit
and now they're part of these these
numbers that we see and they you know
eventually do prove obviously um
these things but but getting ahead of
this and allowing folks do this online
would help to eliminate some of those
numbers it would give the attorney
general more time to use their limited
resources on uh folks who uh maybe
didn't use you know they're trying to
track down these folks they try to track
down after elections and so for those
reasons i think it's a good tool to help
us get in front of some of these numbers
that we see and for people have an
easier time proving who they you know
say they are where they say they live um
and so that would be the reason why you
know part of the reason we're supporting
this here today and i'm happy to take
any questions about it
thank you
questions
i i have a question sure brian
as i'm listening to all this wonderful
information that you can get
online talking to somebody who hates
having to get online for anything
i heard one of the things that would say
that you put in a couple of pieces of
data
and you get to pick i think the example
this morning was your phone number so
depending on the design of the system
do you agree that you might be able to
find your way into somebody else's
information and i say that speaking to
someone who i recall at prior hearings
saying something which we're not
supposed to i just said don't do
talking about how common a name some
people have and that by that's a good
one that was a long time ago we had that
conversation you can input it and
end up
with somebody completely different so
here's what i'll say about this portal
that we've seen i think new hampshire
isn't now a very small minority of
states that don't have some sort of
online portal that they can use to
register to vote or to update addresses
or update information um so we don't
luckily we don't need to start from
scratch here and figuring this out we
have i think last time i knew and i
don't i can email the query but i think
it's 39 or 40 states have some sort of
online portal where folks can register
including other states that are nvra
exempt states or motor voter exempt
states um
and so luckily
we can look to them because these folks
have been doing this and it's not new
anymore
we're talking about something that
states started doing over a decade ago
finally doing here and so
we can look to them and help figure out
what safeguards they use to make sure
that the right michael o'brien
is the one that's accessing that record
it's also important to note that
ultimately the final decision here still
rests with the supervisor of the
checklist the supervisor sees something
that they feel isn't quite right that
doesn't quite you know
compute for them they still have the
ultimate say on if that name goes on the
checklist or not right this is not an
automatic voter registration program or
automated voter registration program as
listener charlie just said and so i
think there are safeguards with the
system and we can look to other places
to figure out how best to secure
the information that we're talking about
and
seeing nobody else on the committee
follow i'll see recognize representative
prudhomme o'brien i just wanted to make
a personal comment about common names i
am not related to the
man speaking right now and
the reason i have such a long name and
two last names is because the last name
is so common and i have experienced a
lot of problems such as almost getting a
medical procedure that i was not signed
up for
because there was another kathy o'brien
and that's not really my name but that
was her name and she was in the waiting
room and she has a lot of problems
listen i've been uh you know this was a
long time ago probably uh in a different
time in history but when i was younger
had been uh my name was on a list and i
went into the airplane because there was
a michael o'brien probably somewhere in
ireland or northern ireland i suspect
that got flagged for some reason right
but they were able to determine who i
was there were steps to be taken to
figure out that the little 12 year old
boy who was trying to get on the
airplane was not the same one they were
looking for
um
and that's the point here right is there
are steps that you can take there are
places we can look to help figure this
out this is not new this is not we're
not venturing into some unknown land
that we've never been to before um and
so there are answers here that we can
find and i think we you know i saw the
secretary of state has put out an rfp
for a program like this um and i'm sure
the vendors can help explain that and
make sure that we're finding the right
folks
all right and then my my fa
representative william
thank you madam chair um
i just want to clarify that you're not
the honorable state representative from
nashua is that correct i am not the
honorable because as he would often tell
me when i uh worked in the democratic
caucus that uh he's the original michael
o'brien uh
great thank you yes
i would like to ask your
opinion on the development of this
because you just spoke to the fact that
we have other states that we can go to
and
you heard the sponsor ask be asked a
question about a study committee
so
this bill proposes that our government
bureaucracies themselves develop this
portal
there is no outside
input this bill proposes the secretary
of state consulting with dit department
of safety division of motor vehicles
city and tower clerks supervisors of the
checklist
do you have any experience with other
legislation dealing with this type of a
thing as to whether or not
those things either have an oversight or
people other than
employees of the bureaucracy overseeing
it
i guess i don't have a good i would have
to think about that i don't think that i
have personal experience with that i
will say that again i think if we look
at other states um you can see that this
is the way they're developed and and the
fact that we're talking about
supervisors and clerks and moderators
having this voice is really important i
also i would have to look at the
effective date but i don't think it's
tomorrow right i think there's a bit of
time here for this to be developed in a
way that 60 days
but i've it within the i'd have to look
at the bill that's probably from passage
but then there's a time before the
system becomes live oh yeah correct so
there's going to be time for this thing
to be built out this is not for 2022
we're not trying to like jam this in in
the next six months i think it's
probably before the 2024 election and so
there is time for this to be built out
in an appropriate way
within this
bill further questions from mr o'brien
seeing none thank you for joining us
this morning also signed up to speak on
sb 425 it's olivia zink
olivia zinc open democracy and we're in
support of 425
i just want to speak to a couple of
things um i think it's really important
that we have a clean checklist
that the checklists are are updated and
that we know what are the voters i was
once checking in voters and somebody
came their last name was t
o
and
they weren't there and i was like you're
not a registered voter and they said to
me well i've voted before
and i just happened to check and they
were under the checklist as t a
and when the supervisor put them in they
made a mistake because their handwriting
they and we we pulled back the form and
we could understand how the supervisor
of the checklist made that that error on
the checklist but i think if people are
putting typing in their own name you're
likely not to have those kind of errors
happen um i just checked the national
committee on state legislators said
there's 42 states that have these kind
of other systems to answer that question
this bill has is not a new idea i think
it's been floating around the
legislature for at least six years
in concept form so as far as studying i
feel like it gets better and better each
time it's been introduced
to the point of the fiscal note it did
not cost california
this much money to implement a program
like that and i would venture to guess
california has a lot more registered
voters than we do in new hampshire so i
don't think the fiscal note will be
quite so high
as what is being proposed and i want to
remind the committee that the cost of
keeping the checklist up to date is
actually on the backs of our local
communities it costs about three to four
dollars to register to input the data
between the clerks and the supervisors
of the checklist many communities don't
pay their supervisors the checklist but
a lot of them do pay their supervisors
of the checklist to come in and enter
that data and it is about three to four
dollars per
person that they entered in and that
cost currently is being paid for
by cities and towns and so this does
centralize those costs and can save
municipal
communities a little bit of money on
that registration
but that i'm happy to take any questions
thank you any questions for ms zinke
i'm not seeing any thank you for coming
um that is the last card i have for 425
is there anybody else who wants to speak
to 425
seeing none i'm gonna close the public
hearing on 4
25 and it looks to me that we might be
right at 11 o'clock
so i am going to move on and open the
public hearing
on 4 18.
um senator guida it was
has sent a message that he is not
available
uh for a little bit i suspect that this
will take until at least that point
um representative tarosian would you
would you
representative
sorry senator
greywood if uh since it came out of my
committee i'd be happy to if you
wouldn't mind having us
seat and introducing it just to tell us
it's yours now and we'll move on to
public testimony i understand senator
guida is planning on being here later
and will recognize him when he arrives
excellent
thank you
my name is james gray i'm a senator from
district six
um and this is uh
senate bill 418 uh relative to the
verification of voter affidavits
um
as i've tested fired earlier today
certainly it is
my intention that
we make it as
unobtrusive as possible for people to
vote
and one of the amendments that you'll
actually see in there
talks about uh
uh that was incorporated into the bill
talks about being able to use uh prior
election data uh to verify
um some of the information that's in
there
uh many people have talked about the
constitutionality of this bill
um whether or not it will be found by
the courts
certainly
i consulted as chair of the senate
election law committee
with
various attorneys on that
and i got a variety of answers
but
to sum up what my opinion after talking
to all of those
people is that on its face this bill is
not unconstitutional
that
but then when you look at the
supreme court decision
about
sb3
that
talking about long lines talking about
other things that are in there that are
not really provisions of the bill but
were reported to be
consequences of the bill and that's why
i believe that
that cutting down that number of people
who would have to fill out an affidavit
in the first place
um
and
some of the things that that aren't in
this bill that you may want to consider
you know ways to reduce that number of
lists or collect additional data
that would help you
find that individual afterward
the secretary of state's office i
believe will testify on whether or not
this bill would cause a problem
with
the general election if done in the
primary or other elections
so i won't need to go there
but uh
this does not uh create
it creates an affidavit ballot and the
reason
that we use that term instead of
provisional ballot
uh is to distinguish it from
uh
the characteristics of the provisional
ballot so uh
if you have any more questions since i'm
just a substitute here
i'll try to answer them but uh when
senator guida does get here or the other
people who testify behind me uh
certainly
they can answer things i can't
thank you senator questions
representative bergeron thank you thank
you madam chair
senator this is probably a question i
think you might be able to help us out
with
during senate testimony
didn't
secretary of state scanlan suggest that
the senate might want to table it and
ask for an opinion from the supreme
court on the constitutionality of of
this bill and
since that wasn't done could you explain
that the reasons behind that why not
certainly um
to be able to do that in the senate we
would have to create a resolution uh
take the bill that was
the subject of that resolution
and then
pass the resolution and send it off to
the supreme court
right now
to do that would take this bill and
and move it at least to the next
legislative session since there was
still work going on in this bill up
until about a week and a half before
crossover and you know that
once i get to crossover
if it's the senate bill i lose my
ability to take action on it this year
so for all those reasons
as i did testify originally you know i
did consult with various attorneys
on the constitutionality of this bill uh
some said it was constitutional some
said it wasn't constitutional
but
the ones who said it wasn't
um
ben you know
led me to go back and look at the
decision on sb3 and read that from the
supreme court and the reasons that they
used and that again the amendment that
you see in there about using
prior data other data that's in the
election database to be able to to cut
down on the process time etc
was
one of the reasons why that was done
thank you further questions from
committee members for senator gray
representative teresian
thank you madam chair thank you again
senator for taking the question
so just to kind of follow up on that a
little bit um
there's been some chatter suggesting
that this would have a
legal problem uh some of the senate bill
3 but are you confident that
it's different enough
that this should pass any kind of legal
challenge
i would answer that question by telling
you that
i have been surprised many times
by decisions of both the new hampshire
supreme court
and the supreme court of the united
states
and so my confidence
uh i really can't speak to it because of
the number of times i was surprised
further questions from committee members
seeing none thank you senator
representative morehead
thank you madam chair
um is it would you uh accept another
question oh i thought i thought i was
done yeah sorry i said thank you and
then i said as i was turning my head i
saw a report representative
as many as many questions you've got
i'll attempt to answer all right
remember we have the sponsor of the bill
coming later thank you oh we do okay yes
uh i thought we the sponsor wasn't
coming i'm so sorry i i'll pass but
thank you for so generously offering to
answer the question
thank you all right now any more
questions for senator gray before i
thank him for being here all right
that's it i think i've seen everybody
now thank you senator all right all
right we have a number as you all might
suspect a number of people signed up to
speak on this bill we are going to limit
testimony to three minutes
to make sure and i need to tell you at
that we are still well over an hour
um so with that i'm going to
um
go start going through my pink cards and
i won't be surprised if i continue to
get them throughout the hearing and the
first person i'm going to recognize here
is sue nastasi from rawlingsford
slashdover
oh sorry did you not want the honors of
going first come on up
all right good
come on up
yes
um sunastasi a voter in rollinsford one
of the town's three
supervisors of the checklist
planning board member
and proudly illegal women voters new
hampshire state board member
but
chair miss barbara griffith and members
of the election law committee
thank you for your time to discuss
senate bill 418.
there are three main issues why i'm here
opposing this bill
first in the case of a registered voter
that does not have their id available or
a resident wants to register on election
day but without enough id
the provisional ballot plus possible new
voter pack packet causes lines and
confusion
next remember when the september primary
is
but you will cover the military or those
citizens overseas
the ballots must be mailed 45 days
before the general election
there is a strong possibility that those
ballots will not be received to be
counted
those ballots do not count they're not
received they're not counted
next there are privacy issues when a
ballot must be pulled by the moderator
names matched and sent to concord
when the voter did not contact the town
city or city clerk with complete
documentation
election night results are just sort of
totals
subject to change 10 days later
these sort of totals for new hampshire
and being first in the nation state
with the
election results
that is a very difficult to take on the
national scene
quotes from coelection day workers the
bill
the quote
it is a solution in search of a problem
where or who will foot the bill for the
27 prepaid mailers the state
or town city
uh downshifting to local levels of
expenses exists
the current affidavit used on election
day is sufficient
without the provisional ballot
as one of rawlinsford's supervisors i
look forward to being serviceable to the
voters
use the right to vote without worry of
the constitutional right of privacy
the right to register and vote on
election day
i can visualize an example of a parent
carrying a very young child arriving at
the polling location picked up from a
sitter after work and the supervisor
asked for an id that by chance was
forgotten
the parent is tired very tired and he or
she must go through extra procedures to
be sure
his or her vote counts
a photo must be taken clip it to
paperwork and the additional chore
receiving so you know you know you're at
three minutes so we're going to ask you
to finish up okay oh
i didn't realize
but thank you i'll tell you an old trick
when i started this i used to time
myself on the microwave before i
microwaved it
i couldn't figure out how to work the
clock on my phone
well encourage voters
and um
i want to thank you for your time i ask
you for all to support who you are
serving your constituents the voters
and i'm sorry
um i have to give shout out of terrific
trisha
um that trains and takes care of all the
helpline people
for all um the supervisors
oh the best you know at first i was
concerned when new or calling the
helpline ah
but it's okay
they're terrific
and they really are and i brought my uh
campaign button when i first ran this
supervisor
this was made in your house
senator gray
yes
from his uh campaign machine
but secrets secret secrets here yeah
unknown facts
all unrelated so i let her go over the
three minutes because it was just okay
but thank you for your time thank you
for coming dude would does anybody have
any questions ma'am sure representative
bergeron would like to ask you a
question
are you okay
you don't have to take it if you don't
want okay
representative bergeron is usually
pretty nice i try to be kind so i won't
i won't put you on a spot but
this is a question i think is perfect
first to ask of a supervisor of the
checklist uh at the polls what's your
role is it to register people to vote
yes that's part of it yes okay um
currently i'm sorry follow up
currently if someone goes to the
checklist
and doesn't have an id they're directed
to go to a no id table where they fill
out the affidavit and uh and have their
picture taken
this bill would require the voter to go
to your table the voter registration
table even though they're already
registered to vote
at that point you redirect them back to
the moderator for the no id table and
they have to fill out the affidavit and
have their picture done
does it make any sense to you that the
voter is going to have to get away from
the checklist wait in line at your table
only to be sent over to the see the
moderator
well i guess it's situational uh per
town of uh exact placement and uh
sequence of events
um but
i do know
um
in rollinsford
that when uh
they don't have their id with the ballot
clerk
and they come to the one of three of us
and
um if the other busy i'm here to um
make sure that they fill out the
affidavit
and uh let them know to um you know
bring in their
their id and um
but maybe due to the size of uh
rollinsford that if they don't bring it
in uh everyone seems to know who to call
to get their id
and um
and it's it's fine it's um it's amazing
uh
if um even if someone
doesn't have their id and then there's a
uh um
recognizing um some people
um i know some people have um
lived forever and generations in one
little locale but um
yeah it's so for rollinsford that they
fill out the affidavit
and they take get the photo
and um
and then go back ballot clerk
and everything's fine okay thank you
any further questions
see none thank you
thank you also signed up to speak on
this bill is louise spencer
i can't hear i can't understand you
um
i'll do him next how about we do that
what was the name
dr parentovich he had put his card up
and it got lost in the shuffle well i
mean i'm getting him okay yes
okay thank you so much all right go
ahead
hi my name is louise spencer
and um i'm from concord new hampshire
and i am the co-founder of the country
coalition which is an all volunteer
grassroots advocacy organization
i'm speaking here today on my own behalf
but i know for a fact that many many
members of our organization
signed in on
this bill to oppose it
and that i feel very comfortable
saying that kent street opposes this
bill
um what i'd like to speak to is
following up
on the prior
what the prior speaker spoke to
which is the logistical nightmare that
this bill
would present
for
um
on election day and it speaks to many of
the issues that were raised in the sb3
lawsuit
in terms of the amount of extra time
that will be added to
the process of registering to vote and
voting
so
that i know that there's an effort to
try to provide alternative ways to
verify
voter information um for those voters
who are already
registered but perhaps don't have their
id
when i
observed the election in windham
recently
i spoke to the supervisors of the
checklist there
they said it's one thing if it's a slow
election
but when it's a busy general election
particularly a presidential election
they have very little time to do
anything
but to actually register
the voters and move them along
so they have very little time to get on
a computer to check election net
and often
during a very busy election election net
is down and they can't even access that
information
at all
so we're talking about adding a whole
another layer of process
on top of
in busy
precincts a process that's already
can result in lines so i think when
we're talking about a small town this
may not appear to have much of an impact
but if you've ever been to elections in
durham or windham or hanover or some of
the places where
in manchester
where you
tend to
get long lines anyway
as soon as you start adding on extra
steps and extra process you
start adding extra time
and that is something that
creates difficulties
for the voter and certainly for election
officials so i really urge you to vote
itl on this bill so thank you very much
thank you any questions for ms spencer
representative bergeron
sorry kevin
representative teresian thank you madam
chair ma'am thank you for taking the
question
so under current law is it more
efficient and more timely if the voter
when they come to the polls has a
you know valid id with them
it certainly is and when i go out and do
to speak with voters i always encourage
them to bring
the documentation whatever documentation
that will help make the process as
smooth as possible i would love to see
us do more education prior to elections
so that voters are
really aware of what they need to bring
that's not always clear on town and city
websites and i think we could do a huge
effort in terms of voter education about
what can make the process go smoother
smoother i'm also aware as someone spoke
to about you know the mother that shows
up quickly after work having picked up
her kid at child care oh my gosh i
forgot my license um that that happens
it's going to happen
the other issue i would point out is
that
this was a purge year
and a lot of people are going to be
showing up thinking that they are on the
rolls
only to find out they aren't and they
will not necessarily come with their
passport in hand and their birth
certificate in hand because
they will think that they've already
established those qualifications
sure further questions from committee
members
seeing none thank you thank you all
right next to speak
nick
thank you so i i would i'm not going to
beg for forgiveness i'm going to ask you
to just pronounce your name then thank
you
my name is nick prensovich i was in a
lived in concord for 34 years um retired
now
when i read about this bill it
i'd like to focus pretty much on the
absentee ballot part which has already
been mentioned briefly
i have i like to ask the comm thank you
for allowing me to speak thank you just
excuse me for a minute for committee
members you're going to have to share a
little bit on this we don't have 20
copies i don't have enough i'm sorry
okay
um i'd like to start my testimony by
asking the committee a question have you
seen the movie saving private ryan it's
been over 20 almost 25 years so uh that
movie came out in 1988 i saw it with my
my wife and friends and before it left
the movie theaters then there wasn't any
hbo thing that
i uh
got my three late teenage children to go
see the movie with me which i don't
think i had done before since i wanted
them to see that first 23 minutes if you
remember the movie it was pretty stark
about uh
invading omaha beach on june 6 1944
and uh
i remember when we got out of the movie
one of my children said so what's the
message dad and i said well if i find
out you don't vote i'm going to disown
you and you're all about to go to
college
and i i track it they do vote
i did i looked up a little history
because it was a personal thing to me in
some extent during world war ii it was
very hard to get those gis to get the
vote so they passed the bill on 42
saying
um
we'll send them absentee ballots but it
wasn't happening so by 44 right about
the time of d-day
uh more emphasis was pushed on the state
to do it
and
it didn't work all that well either i
mean there was a lot of it was not
coincidental because d-day was in the
news and so forth
um
going fast forward a bit in the 70s i
found myself living in scotland
for two years and i wanted to vote in
the election at that point my residence
being was massachusetts it was a bit of
a problem getting they have seen ballot
but i got it and i voted
and then two years later i found myself
living for two years as an active duty
person in the air force
and when i was overseas then it was also
a challenge my my state at that point by
record was massachusetts so i
i felt at that point something better
ought to happen and it did in 1986 under
the reagan administration
they passed the uoca va the thing that
you're all talking about and it's
uniformed
and overseas citizens so back when i was
in scotland for a year i was an overseas
citizen they fit that category and
that's where you heard all the rules
about 45 days i'm not going to go over
it because it's already been mentioned
so basically this bill makes it really
hard for that absentee valid not only
for the uniform folks but anybody who's
working a job let's say in london for a
year or two
to get through and vote
not only in this primary but in general
the general election will be very
difficult
adding the 10 to 14 days makes it
virtually impossible so
my final comment is basically uh you
know let's not forget what those folks
did on omaha beach
this law that was based on the
reagan administration is a really good
idea
and and should be enforced and i think
the solution i have to believe the
people who wrote this bill just didn't
think about this
but if you're going to pass this bill
and you want a solution one of two
things either you lengthen the time
between the primary and the election
so you've got those 14 days kicked in
and you still have 45 days or the option
is make it possible like 31 other states
we're in a group of 19 that you can't do
an absentee ballot electronically so
that may be even a quicker solution you
might even have time between now and the
fall
and that's all i'd like to say thank you
very much for your testimony does
anybody have any questions for the
witness
seeing none thanks for joining us good
morning
also signed up to speak on this bill is
lisa denis
good morning
my written testimony should have been
submitted online okay great
i promise i'm not going to read this
binder
good morning
my name is lisa danis and i am
testifying on behalf of the brennan
center for justice about the significant
chance that new hampshire will lose its
exemption to the national voter
registration act if it passes senate
bill 418.
i have been working on nvra
implementation and enforcement for over
15 years
and uh in fact i brought with me today
one of the original paper handbooks on
implementation of the nvra
you can see
the handbook is hundreds of pages long
detailing requirements that new
hampshire will have to implement and
comply with if it loses its exemption
and losing its exemption is a one-way
street
once new hampshire loses its exemption
it cannot get it back
sb 418 could cost new hampshire its
exemption for two reasons at least
first sb 418 would be a substantive
change to election day registration such
that the law likely will not qualify as
in effect continuously and therefore
the law that triggered the exemption
will no longer remain in effect
second
sb 418 changes the edr law so that not
every eligible voter is able to register
at the polling place a key requirement
of the nvra exemption
if new hampshire loses its nvra
exemption the law
must be implemented immediately
and new hampshire will face multiple
consequences requiring money time and
staffing resources
i'm going to try to get through the
whole list of what new hampshire will
have to do i don't know if i can do it
in the time limit but i'll try i'll
actually stipulate you
can't how's that all right well i'll do
my best
[Laughter]
first new hampshire so my suggestion is
if there's something
you want to say in conclusion to the
list because i'm pretty familiar i know
i'm familiar with the list so go ahead
okay all right so first new hampshire
will have to begin offering simultaneous
drivers license and voter registration
applications in person and online and
will have to do the same for driver's
license renewal applications it will
have to implement robust voter
registration services as part of each
application renewal and change of
address through any agency providing
public assistance and any state-funded
office primarily serving people with
disabilities
these changes require new hampshire to
design and distribute new forms rewrite
policies and retrain employees at all of
these agencies
new hampshire would have to begin
accepting the federal mail voter
registration form from any eligible
citizen who submits it this could
greatly increase the volume of new
hampshire voters using mail registration
and also would preclude new hampshire
from requiring
the federal form to be notarized or
requirement that a voter provide
documentary proof of citizenship
new hampshire would have to change the
way election officials handle
voter list maintenance and purging the
nvra regulates list maintenance in a lot
of ways including a bar on systemic
removal of voters within 90 days of any
federal election and removing voters for
suspicion
sorry for inactivity without first
sending a specific notice
and waiting through two federal election
cycles
and significantly
if new hampshire fails to implement any
of these new requirements does so out of
compliance with the statute or fails to
take the requirements seriously the
state can be sued indeed should expect
to be sued
by the department of justice or private
litigants and any private party that
prevails against the state would be able
to seek payment of attorneys fees costs
and expenses i'm going to need you to
wrap up okay i think you wouldn't make
thank you for the opportunity to testify
i urge this committee to refrain from
advancing this
any questions
representative barry
thank you thank you for taking my
question so when i read this bill uh the
first thing i saw was they're trying to
find a way
to get around the nvra um
i'm a fan of the nvra um there's things
in the mvra that i really like um like
we could get rid of same-day
registration and have a robust
registration program before the day
thereby ending the lines on election day
smoothing up the process of um
of of getting people through
through to the ballot um we could do
other things such as not having a
10-year purge where if the if the like
right now we just did our purge and our
voter rolls shrank 25
which means 25 percent of our voter roll
was inaccurate we can't do it any more
often than that because we're not in
nvra we can't actually require somebody
to show an id when they're registering
to vote or voting because of the nvra
because we're not doing these things so
you're you're saying that with this bill
we would trigger the nvra and new
hampshire would go under the nvra and
then we could implement the other
provisions of the nvra
uh you would have to implement the other
provisions of the npra thank you
further questions
representative wilhelm
thank you madam chair and thanks for
taking my question uh do you have a
sense of how much it would cost the
state of new hampshire to implement uh
the nva ra programs that you outlined so
there is an independent estimate of that
and if it's okay it's actually in the
text on my phone is it okay for me to
get that out sure sure go ahead
i got that estimate just before i walked
in the door so
um
an independent estimate has put it at
6.5 million dollars in upfront costs
2.5 million dollars annually and then
whatever is awarded as part of
attorney's visas costs and expenses in
the litigation that's sure to come
thank you
you're welcome further questions
seeing none thank you
thank you so much
also signed up to speak on this bill is
uh
peter
vasilia from milford
uh thank you madam chair my name is
peter bassellier i'm the um i'm from
milford i am the town moderator and the
school district moderator and i've been
serving in those roles
since 2008.
my goal as a moderator as i've said many
times over the years is to ensure that
we have a safe secure and trustworthy
election
i i'm opposed to the
legislation the as as proposed
and as amended as i understand it i
provided the committee with a lengthy uh
email
last night
i don't intend to go into that in detail
today unless you prompt me to
but i would like to point out 5.5
important items that relate to the
proposed legislation
first is that there is no definition of
affidavit valid
and by that i'm talking about the
definition the description of the actual
ballot itself what does it look like
in and one point to consider is does it
need to have the phrase affidavit ballot
printed on the document
there's nothing in the language that
addresses how this will look what kind
of paper it ought to be on is it a
colored paper if it's a colored paper
but how do we distinguish it between
uh other ballots
um you know at a primary election for
example
and um
another aspect of this legislation is
that it is going to be very difficult to
disguise a voter's name
um and
keeping that person's uh
confidential if their
ballot is removed from the tally
in milford we have almost 10 000
registered voters and at the march
election last month we had one abs uh
cva
so if that person um had doesn't provide
the appropriate documentation to the
secretary of state within 10 days that
person is going to be there their vote
is going to be removed
now
during the course of the day depending
upon what that ballot looks like
voters who are in the polling place
election officials who are in the
polling place will know that though
there's the one person that went through
had an affidavit ballot
and is now their vote is being removed
because they didn't provide um
documentation in a timely fashion
this gets me to another very important
point
and that is the uh the 10 days
within which the voter has to provide
the necessary information
i think that's a serious uh flaw
because
it what happens if a person mails the
package to
the secretary of state's office
on the 10th day
and it arrives at the secretary of
state's office on the 12th or 13th day
because of a a weekend or a holiday
i
suggest strongly that you consider a
postmark
that the packet has to be postmarked
by a certain date so that everybody
knows including the voter and the voter
can prove to anybody after the fact that
they did submit their their
documentation
and indeed if they were to be wrongly
removed because they did provide the
information at least they would have
evidence to show to the secretary of
state that i did my part the postal
service for whatever reason did not
deliver on time
thank you if you could wrap up
i'm sorry if you could wrap up just over
the three minutes um
the other is what i would really like to
suggest
is based on partly on my experience back
in 2013 when we were 15 when we first
had the voter id
photo id
the very first person to come into the
milford polling place and asked me to
vouch for them
no lie
was senate president peter bragdon
it was march election he left his um his
id out in the car and he had to get the
carcad as quickly as possible
i think that if you were to make this
work focus please on
the people who are trying to register
the vote and don't have the necessary
information but if a voter like mr
bragnan or like myself i've been voting
in town for many many decades now if we
know that those people are already
registered and they only forgot their
id why do we ask them to go out to the
car why do we ask them to go home let's
have them fill out the cva
and just follow the normal course as it
exists today but have a separate if you
wish process for the newly registered
vote or the voter who would like to
register and does not have the necessary
information
let's not penalize the people who have
made a sincere effort to come to the
polls
and vote by having them do something
that a person who is voting by absentee
does not have to do thank you thank you
are there any questions i'm sure
representative bergeron thank you madam
chairman and thank you for your
testimony
the talk about the need to describe what
an affidavit ballot is
there's a provision in state law 656 16
which currently states there shall be no
impression or mark to distinguish one
general election ballot from another end
quote and
that's not being um
repealed under house senate bill 418
in your opinion as a moderator where the
bill says the moderator shall mark each
affidavit ballot affidavit ballot number
such
uh wouldn't that be in conflict with
existing law that there shall be no
impression or mark placed on the ballots
to distinguish them it would certainly
seem to be okay thank you
further questions representative
can you pretend
tallersky thank you madam chairman thank
you
thank you for taking my question uh the
way you described um
your example of having one challenge
voter affidavit
when you at the end of the night pull
out all the ballots and sort them and
just count them to make sure that your
numbers all line up what i understand is
that if you have that one
yellow ballot or marked ballot whatever
the election officials who know that
john doe
filled out that one would be able to see
exactly
who he voted for is did i understand
that correctly yes no that's that's
correct under the proposal if um if
there's the one affidavit ballot um and
um whoever's whatever whoever the
election official is that is handling
that ballot will if they know who
completed the ballot they'll know how
they voted absolutely
but we also on the other hand we also
trust our election officials and when
i'm assisting a voter i'm not really
looking at how they vote and so we're
still in that process while it it's
entirely possible for a for me pulling
the ballot out of the box of the pocket
on the side of the accuvope machine in
order to have it counted by hand um the
bigger point is that that ballot if it's
distinguished enough so that it's it's
different from the town or the school or
the primary or the general election
ballot that whatever the election is
other people who are in the polling
place who are not constrained by
election law to handle this information
confidentially will have an idea of who
that individual was and how they voted
if the tally is removed
thank you very much further questions
seeing none thank you thank you i'm sure
also signed up to speak is linda bundy
welcome back this week
good morning madam chair and members of
the house election law committee my name
is linda bundy i'm from antrim
i agree with governor sununu that new
hampshire's election process has
integrity
that it works and that our this our
citizens believe in our system
causes cases of fraudulent voting are
rare in 2016 over six thousand voters
signed domicile affidavits
only 66 could not be verified
the attorney general's office said that
these do not necessarily represent fraud
rather an investigation that could not
be closed
sb 418
will require that when voters do not
have valid voter ids and do not mail in
missing documents within 10 days their
votes will be deducted from the count
final election results may be delayed as
much as 14 days after the election
this delay affects the votes of active
service members and other citizens
living outside of the united states
by law they are required to receive
ballots at least 45 days before federal
elections which may not be possible
under sb 418.
this situation could violate new
hampshire's motor voter exception to the
national voter registration act governor
sununu said that this legislation would
be contrary to that agreement
the process involved with this proposed
affidavit ballot is likely to confuse
voters some may decide not to vote
others may not understand what to do
with the packet and not follow through
after voting
lines at the polls will move more slowly
as election workers take the time to
explain the affidavit affidavit packet
to voters the packet will incur the
added expense of a prepaid overnight
mailing envelope
secretary of state scanlon has said that
additional temporary staff will have to
be hired to handle the workload
resulting from the ballots
the affidavit ballot process has the
potential to violate the privacy of the
vote
after 10 days the secretary of state's
office will notify towns which ballots
are missing required documents town
officials will retrieve those ballots
and deduct the votes from the final
counts
especially in small towns but really in
any town the identity of the voters
could be known
the prime sponsor of sb 418 has said
that voters just have to sign a piece of
paper to vote without valid photo ids
however they are not simply signing a
paper they are signing an affidavit a
legal document and swearing to and
affirming the truth of their statements
conviction of lying on an affidavit has
consequences of a fine up to five
thousand dollars and up to one year in
jail
sb 418 is unnecessary it attempts to
solve a problem that doesn't exist
by alleging fraud it sows distrust among
voters it creates hurdles that will
suppress the vote when our elections are
already secure
accurate and reliable
democracy works when people participate
i urge you to oppose this bill and i
thank you for this time
thank you for coming does anybody have
any questions for ms bundy
i'm not seeing any thanks
also signed up to speak on this bill is
jessica grill and um if you if you want
to come on senator guida i have not uh
missed you i'm going to call you next
okay because i know you you've got other
you want to wait a little bit okay i
didn't want to infringe on whatever else
you might have on your schedule today
thank you welcome miss grill good
morning madam chair and members of the
committee and um i'd like to start by
thanking you for your time and the
opportunity to appear today
over the last two years i've had the
unique opportunity to participate in our
democracy by
volunteering in the town of bedford's
elections
my experience has shown me how dedicated
new hampshire election officials are to
running fair free and honest elections
and has given me an understanding of the
checks and balances that are currently
in place to ensure that all votes are
cast legally and that all eligible
voters have the opportunity to make
their voices heard
rather than protect election integrity
sp 418 would hamper the elections
process by adding additional redundant
steps for those registering to vote for
the first time as well as voters who do
not have identification with them at the
polls
implementing these steps would create
difficulty for election officials
requiring additional staffing and
funding
furthermore the 10-day waiting period
for affidavit verification would
inevitably delay the process of
finalizing and certifying vote totals
at a time when election officials have
already faced unprecedented controversy
this additional roadblock could inspire
further distrust in our elections as
well as encourage bad faith actors to
promote accusations of fraud or
wrongdoing
for voters sb 418's affidavit
verification requirements negate the
privacy that are is currently insured by
secret ballots
currently affidavit voters are given the
same paper ballot as all other voters
paired with an affidavit form ensuring
that their vote is legitimate
however sb418 would require that
affidavit ballots are given a unique
identifier to track the ballot for
removal if the packet of information
given to the voter is not returned to
the polling place within 10 days
it bears noting that the contents of
this packet are not outlined in this
bill so it's unknown how deeply
this packet distribution process will
complicate on-site voting
the unique identifier also means the
poll workers could potentially identify
who voters cast their ballots for
the senate committee heard testimony
from local elections officials
expressing their concern about compiling
the sensitive information and for good
reason
these privacy concerns coupled with the
time needed to complete these steps
creates a two-tiered voting system with
the likely impact of discouraging
turnout
i also have concerns regarding the
unknown fiscal impact of sb418 on the
state and local level
the fiscal note associated with the bill
states that an indeterminable increase
in expenditures would be needed in order
to fund the materials and labor needed
to implement this new system
it's unlikely that these costs will come
cheap and these new resources would be
necessary for all future elections
given the potential harms of this bill
and the rarity of fraudulent voting it's
only fair that stakeholders are given a
clear understanding of the additional
costs sb418 would incur i ask that the
committee reconsider whether it's
appropriate to invest these expenditures
and additional bureaucratic resources
into such drastic reforms
i strongly oppose sb418 and i urge all
committee members to vote against its
passage this bill takes drastic steps to
complicate election administration and
delay vote counting creates unnecessary
difficulties for countless voters and
has have
and as others have stated particularly
marginalizes our overseas military
voters
if this committee is truly concerned
with election irregularities members
ought to consider strategies that
streamline and modernize the voting
process like enrolling in the electronic
registration information center
and implementing an online voter
information portal instead of enacting
more burdensome expensive and punitive
legislation
new hampshire voters election officials
and taxpayers deserve better solutions
than sb418 thank you for your time
thank you for your testimony thank you
for working in bedford at the polls does
anybody have any questions
seeing none thank you for joining us
this morning
also signed up to speak on this bill is
representative tim horrigan
sorry i just realized you were sitting
there so come on up
three minutes
i have um two
i have a i have some written testimony
and then i've got um
i also have a copy of the article from
the union leader today so i guess i'll
uh
don't count this first like three
minutes please i guess i'll start the
ball rolling getting these things passed
around the table hopefully they'll make
it all the way around um
why don't you just hand those to
representative mirner on your left then
good okay we'll just do the passing out
representative mirner drove a long way
today to substitute so we're going to
put him to work
thank you
i'm just in being on my right we're on
we're both on the judiciary committee so
i'm representing timothy horrigan i
represent strafford county district six
the towns of durham and madbury
and um
the uh just
on my
first
my primary objection sb14 my first one
is that it's extraordinarily complicated
and error prone i um one of the things
i'm on the back side of my written
testimony is a letter that was published
in the union leader yesterday where i
described as a rube goldberg scheme
which is
actually unfair to rube goldberg because
his machines actually worked i don't
think this game outlined in the bill is
going to work um
although since i've um
and even i
on further reflection after sitting here
i realized uh first of all the number of
people going to be filling out these
ballots is going to be pretty small
because the number of people actually
show up with
no id and who aren't known to any of the
poll workers is vanishingly small i've
um i worked in a municipal election i
didn't see a single i worked in the
municipal election in march and i didn't
see a single
single person show up without id
although there are people who there are
citizens who for one reason other don't
have their id and still have the right
to vote though so
and that could be especially tragic
given what happened two years ago in the
presidential election and you probably
don't want me to go into that but um any
complication we have is one less thing
for p to be suspicious about when they
don't like the way the election turned
out and
let's keep them as simple secure and
error free as possible so putting in
this thing which is complicated
error-prone and
laughably insecure is a bad idea um
suther said it grossly compromises the
secrecy of the ballot
slows down the count for 14 days and
some cases we might never have a result
that everybody
accepts and that'd be especially tragic
happened during our state primary which
is only eight weeks before the general
election and
[Music]
of course it would be possible to change
the primary date i'm i've mixed feelings
about it and you do have another bill on
it
but sb 418 makes no provision for it
in fact it could in theory be passed and
take effect this year just weeks or even
days before the next primary in
september 13 2022 i mean it could
um
obviously you know it could could even
happen like the week before although
that would have to involve
the bill passing and then being vetoed
and then for some reason being
overwritten which would mean that the
party i belong to the democrats would
have to all flip their votes but
um
so this
you know passing this thing on passage
especially in the middle of an election
season is extremely foolhardy and um the
schemes beers have been hastily cooked
up by a handful of senators
as far as you can tell with no out input
from elections officials certainly we've
heard from several election officials
who
think this is a terrible idea
certainly without any field testing
although i have to confess i'm not
really sure of any way to field test
something like this
um
aside possibly from using it during
municipal elections although even then
municipal actions are quite different
from our
state elections another possibility of
course
we could just field test this during the
2026 presidential primary but um i don't
think anybody wants
a
i think the sponsors certainly don't
want to wait that long and i don't think
the last thing anybody wants to do when
we have
presidential primary which will be which
is often a very close election is to
have this complicated thing that's going
to delay the final result but for two
weeks so the
and also add in the findings they seem
to be worried about multi-voting this
apps does absolutely nothing to prevent
multi-voting as long as a person shows
up
shows up in one state with the popular
id and shows with another another state
being
massachusetts as in the example i'm
passing around or in new jersey is in
the case of a
something that's been in the news lately
um
does absolutely nothing but to um
nothing about that but since some they
wouldn't need to fill out this affidavit
in new hampshire or in the other state
where the person is voting so it doesn't
even solve the problem it's worrying
about which is any case is a rather
um small problem so i think the
best thing to do with this bill is just
kill it like let's not pursue it any
further you know
thank you thank you representative
horrigan are there any questions for
representative horgan
i'm not seeing anything and thank you
for all of the copies of your written
testimony yes i added all the way around
yes i
although i apologize um i i was using
the
um
i was using the old smoking room and i
couldn't figure out how to print it on
and i noticed uh you have been using
apparently you've been using that same
thing before you may or may not be able
to print something so i tried
sending it upstairs and then a new
person upstairs so
the date
there are many i.t challenges to using
the computers around this space yeah so
uh but hopefully anyway that's that's
that's a story that came out today and
the person
not the story about me using the
computer no no no the story about the
man who voted both in san bernardino
massachusetts and actually
he was actually punished much more
harshly than the case that was mentioned
in the in the findings and all right
thank you thank you representative
horgan
also signed up to speak on this bill is
ken eyring
good morning thank you for the
opportunity to talk my name is kennard
nope you were all set my name's ken
eyring i live in windham
windham new hampshire
uh i've listened to a lot of unf
unfounded
arguments that are stirring up fear
regarding this bill
regarding cost whether it's legal or not
and
potential logistical nightmares
and i believe and i hope all of you
believe that there should be no cost
no threshold that should be put on
making sure that our elections are valid
and that only
new hampshire citizens
are enabled to vote in our state
the logistical nightmare arguments that
it will take extra time to vote
that's only if people don't bring their
photo id
adults
are the only people who can vote
based on the voting age
and they need to take personal
responsibility for that
i live in windham
i heard one reference before about the
the uh
the nightmares that might
ensue with long lines
i know two of the supervisors of the
checklist very personally they're my
friends they are frustrated with the
ability of people to vote
with literally being able to sign a
piece of paper with no
proof of who they are
where they live or whether they're a u.s
citizen or not
i've served
during
election day to sign up
voters
and it's really a mockery of our system
how easy it is for anyone to come in and
vote on election day
this bill
gave a lot of consideration in time to
address all the issues that have been
brought up in the past and senator gaida
and others including former chief
justice
bob lynn
chief justice of the new hampshire
supreme court who's also a state rep he
worked on this bill
he supports this bill
and he does not believe
that there will be any issues regarding
new hampshire's exemption if passed
i spoke with him a few minutes ago when
he was sitting back here he had to leave
he gave me permission to make those
statements
you need a license to get on a plane you
need a license to buy alcohol
would you suggest that people be able to
do these activities
by simply signing an affidavit without
proving who they are
i would hope not
the integrity of our elections as
everybody knows after 2020 is important
and in the front of many people's minds
this bill puts a lot of questions and
concerns to rest i urge you to pass this
bill
thank
you
thank you mr eyring
any questions for mr eyring
thank you very much for your testimony
welcome thank you for your time
so this is the next one
okay also signed up to speak we have a
baba and i apologize for
last name i'm going to mispronounce it
passler
i'm not sure if i was close on that
pronunciation or not but
but i'm sorry
like cello
okay
my name is barbara pacelli i live in
concord for 24 years now
and i read on behalf of
okay thank
you paul j hague
from newberry new hampshire
and robin larson from londonderry new
hampshire
as veterans and new hampshire residents
we write to express our strong
opposition to sb 418
when americans join the military we take
an oath to protect and defend the united
states from all enemies from all threats
foreign and domestic
service members should not risk their
lives to protect our rights
only to have their right to vote
put
at risk by laws like sb 418
[Music]
this bill as currently written is
unconstitutional
and is an unacceptable threat to the
right to vote of military members
stationed overseas
in new hampshire the timeline
for uniformed and overseas citizens
absentee voting act ballots for active
military members
is already tight
sb 418 would make it nearly impossible
for service members stationed overseas
to receive and return their ballots on
time
this is not a partisan issue
one of us is a registered republican
the others tend to vote democratic
the right to vote transcends partisan
politics
while serving in the u.s military we
relied on absentee ballots to
participate in the democratic process
during our many years of service
today as veterans we stand united in
support for the right to vote
current service members deserve better
than to have their vote
their right to vote taken away
simply because they are stationed
overseas protecting our country
frankly it is outrageous and a breach of
faith that the new hampshire legislature
would seek to enact a law that in any
way shape or form
restricts impedes or denies a service
member's
right to participate in the most basic
of constitutionally
provided rights
we urge you to vote no on sb 418
to protect the right of our military and
of all americans to vote
thank you for your time thank you for
your testimony it's there if
representative terozian has a question
if you'll indulge us
thank you madam chair you can turn your
mic back on
great thank you thank you madam chan
thank you ma'am for taking the question
um
could you point out in the proposed
legislation um where it
uh would infringe on the military from
exercising the right to vote
unfortunately i could not point that out
specifically i must say i came here to
read this
on behalf of other people and i'm sure
they could point it out to you
so unfortunately i cannot answer you
directly could i call on someone to
answer that
because i do know someone who else who
testified who could speak to that
um i think that's i'll set we'll wait
for somebody to say it in future
testimony okay thank you thank you i
think it probably has something to do
with the yukaba issue
all right great thank you um daniel here
healey from derry is also with us this
morning
welcome to back to the committee
good afternoon members of the committee
uh thank you for giving me the
opportunity to speak
my name is daniel healey i am the derry
town clerk
and i'm here on behalf of the new
hampshire city and town clerks
association
where he served as co-chair of our
legislative committee and his second
vice president of the association
i would like to offer our opposition to
sb 418
as it is a solution to a problem that
does not really exist
and ends up creating additional issues
if a resident comes to my town office
and registers to vote prior to an
election
before the checklist is closed
they can register with affidavits and
have their name added to the checklist
on election day when they come in to
vote they would not be getting an
affidavit
yet they registered with affidavits
there is also currently no follow up
with voters that register at the town
office for additional proof of
verification
when they use an affidavit but new
registrants on election day
will need to provide proof
we are now treating voters differently
if they cannot make it to the town
office prior to an election
i also question how many voters that
register on election day who end up
following through with sending the
paperwork in on time
as it needs to be received by the
secretary of state within 10 days
mail sometimes is delayed for various
reasons and this could cause many
legitimate votes to be negated to
counter the rare occurrence of an
illegally cast ballot
depending on the number of affidavit
ballots used or lack of voter privacy
could become an issue
if we only have one voter that needs
this type of ballot everyone will know
exactly how they voted and that is a
major issue
the way the bill was written if a person
does not send in the paperwork their
vote for that election will not count
but they will still be added to the
checklist for future elections
for the previously stated reasons i
would recommend this committee to itl
this bill
thank you and i'm open to any questions
thank you mr healey any questions from
mr healey
thank you for coming up and joining us
today thank you
also signed up to speak on this bill is
gail laker phelps
welcome
there you go when the red light goes on
it will be on okay great thank you yes
um chairman griffin and the committee
members my name is gail laker phelps and
i'm from chichester
um
thank you for allowing me to give my
personal opinion on this bill
i feel that this bill would support an
environment that would separate one vote
from another which i think violates
citizens right to a secret and
unidentifiable ballot
in addition
to creating more complexities to our
election process
and more expense
this bill also endangers the
legitimately cast votes of citizens
serving overseas in our military this is
unconscionable and unnecessary
i think the whole thing is unnecessary
um sb 418
would take new hampshire down the
slippery slope of voter suppression by
enabling the invalidation of votes cast
in good
faith i think that's a big concern
i'm worried that we are going down the
path of states like georgia and texas
let's keep new hampshire free
of interference with a citizen's right
to cast a secret ballot
so please uh vote against this bill
sb 418 thank you
thank you for coming does anybody have
any questions
i'm not seeing any
thank you
vincent giambo
and i apologize i know i did that last
name wrong come on up
actually sir everybody gets it wrong so
don't worry about it
all right
i'm vincent giambavo i live in loudoun
new hampshire
um
i come from a family that's often served
in the u.s military
i myself was in the u.s navy in a
helicopter combat support squadron
during the vietnam war
i also serve in the american legion for
more than 20 years
i'm currently the service officer for
post 88 in loudoun
i have seven cousins who served in the
korean war
a brother-in-law and two cousins who
served in vietnam
and several nephews who served in kuwait
and iraq
i believe the vote the right to vote is
perhaps the most important right we have
as a democratic society
so i'm asking
why would anyone vote for a bill that
makes it harder for military people who
are serving our country
and securing our right to vote
to have trouble getting their own votes
it's hard enough to vote when you're
when you're serving we need not make it
more difficult or even impossible to
exercise their vote
themselves
the delay caused by the additional
administrative process this bill creates
to voter registration
can delay getting ballots to a service
men and women serving around the world
and would impede their ability to
exercise the very right to vote for
which they're fighting
it is our military who have secured and
maintained our voting rights since the
revolutionary war was 250 years ago
i think those who followed us in serving
their country should not find it more
difficult to exercise the very rights a
service has secured for all americans
urgent to defeat sb 418 and to protect
the voting rights of military personnel
wherever in the world they may be called
to serve
thank you
thank you for coming
any questions
i'm not seeing any
the honorable bob perry has signed up to
speak on this come on now
great we'll pass that around thank you
thank you
my original presentation was five
minutes and 15 seconds i will knock off
two there you go another legislature
times themselves before they come i like
it
all right
my presentation will bob perry town of
stratford
my presentation will focus on the
introductory paragraph at roman one
among other thoughts
i have a personal interest in the
mention of the 1974 u.s senate campaign
having worked with judge wyman in the
1980s
i could not find and i'm leaving out a
paragraph about that i could not find
the specific reference to the incident
involving the 500 fine
involving double voting in massachusetts
and plymouth new hampshire
however even without the details i will
assume the fine was commensurate with
the crime
and i am grateful that as of today in
america prosecutors and judges still
have discretion in punishing and
sentencing i have witnessed many of them
because the ag was unable to verify the
identity of certain voters no inference
can be drawn there from
thus cannot be used as justification for
this bill
once again i am grateful that as of
today in america the accused are
presumed innocent until proven guilty
the governor has gone beyond rejecting
the unfounded claims of massive voter
fraud made by the former president
instead he has praised the integrity of
the new hampshire vote on multiple
occasions including his formal
post-election statement made
december 2nd 2020 which reads as follows
quote
here in new hampshire our elections are
secure accurate and reliable there is no
question about it
i think i thank
bill gartner our town moderators and
clerks and all local election officials
for delivering results to the people of
new hampshire
timely and accurately just as they have
always done end quote
and i'll skip a couple of paragraphs
where uh the glowing remarks continue
and most recently the governor reprised
his prior remarks during an interview at
wmur saying in part quote our citizens
believe in our system that it does have
integrity
99 of the folks polled say that they
know that the system works very very
well
and that's really where we need to be
end quote
if the governor is correct that there is
99 trust in new hampshire elections why
are we here today further regulating the
franchise with this bill
i suggest this bill or any other will
not fix the one percent that remains
because no legislation will produce that
level of purity or perfection and we
will never know how many people will
decide not to vote
after hearing about the complexities of
418.
conclusions based on extensive research
have demonstrated repeatedly that only a
tiny percentage of miscast votes
involve malice or criminal intent
and that tiny percentage
must not be used to punish voters and
impose greater responsibilities
on poll workers
finding volunteers to work elections
becomes more difficult and demanding
with every new election cycle every new
law every new headline and every new
threat
to election workers this bill will
exacerbate the problem
do i have time madam chair to continue
with my last paragraph i yes you do
we will
thank you thank you
i will finish with this
on a happy note let's commit to
celebrating our right to vote embrace it
as the crown jewel of civic
responsibility and pride give it a
holiday encourage participation through
legislation and celebration
and rejoice in its importance to the
health and security of home and family i
maintain in this political environment
it is important to move
to the global community and it's lean
towards autocracy that democracy in
america
is america's preferred form of
government
i urge itl and thank you
thank you any questions for mr perry
i'm not seeing any thank you
um also signed up to speak on this bill
that is shidiko tara
tarai
hi
and we have your written testimony i'm
passing it out right now
two minutes and
10 seconds see there's a whole bunch of
us out there
dear members of the house election law
committee
and
madam chair thank you
for listening my name is shideko turai
i live in cornish and i have for 43
years
i drove one and a half hours to be here
this morning because i believe
our elections in new hampshire are fair
just as they are
i worry that the many voter bills have
been written intentionally to cast doubt
on the integrity of our elections in new
hampshire
in so many cases on other bills you
oppose i have heard you imply that if it
ain't broke
don't fix it
but sb 418
gives the impression
that there is something wrong with our
voting
system i heard the author of this bill
stand up and say just the opposite
and the senators who voted alongside him
reinforced that idea
i worked at the polls and saw some of my
neighbors who forgot their id or didn't
have a driver's license and they started
to walk away
to the sister of one voter of and his
her brother was a vietnam
veteran
he had some drinking plot problems due
to ptsd and lost his license
i said just have him bring proof of
being a resident like a utility bill
better yet have him go over and talk to
the supervisors of the checklist
they will help him
i mean the election officials knew him
he could fill out an affidavit
to one woman i said
you can fill out an affidavit don't go
because she was heading out the door
she said i'm a republican why would you
help me
she knew me
and many in town know me
i said that all votes count
it doesn't matter what party you come
from
but now
with with senate bill 418 if you fail to
return the documents required by the
affidavit not only your ballot be open
publicly and deducted from the totals
but your name and address will be
forwarded to the new hampshire attorney
general for further investigation this
bill makes demands on eligible voters
that all of them will be able to fulfill
i come from a small town
there are time constraints and fines as
someone else mentioned
please
vote no
on sb418
thank you
thank you very much for coming this
morning any questions from committee
members
i'm not seeing any thank you thank you
also signed up to speak on this bill is
lucas meyer
good morning i am not lucas meyer i was
gonna say i just looked up and i'm like
i know i saw him here he had to leave
and he dropped this on my lap so um
oh okay my name is andrew hosmer i work
with lucas meyer um and i'm reading a
statement from dr robert kiefner from
from concord who wanted this red in all
right could you i'm i apologize with
your permission i'm changing this pink
card from lucas meyer to andrew hosner
that'd be just great and who are you
representing because he did not fill
that out yeah i guess i'm reading just
reading a document on behalf of robert
kiefner from concord who could not be
here uh today it's very brief
and the reason he's not here is he's
with his son who's uh
an army uh pilot um
in washington d.c
uh and i quote my name is robert kiefner
md i practiced family medicine in
concord for over 30 years and was proud
to serve in the medical corps united
states naval reserve for eight years my
son is an active duty aviator in the
army one of my brothers served in
vietnam another in korea
my dad was a naval officer in the
pacific during world war ii and several
uncles served our country from the
beaches of normandy to guadalcanal
in the legislative legislative session
which featured an array of galactically
inane bills targeting public health
reproductive rights and public schools
sb 418 is put forth as a fix to a new
hampshire voting process which is
clearly not broken or engulfed in fraud
i would just highlight the effect that
this voter suppression bill might have
upon active duty military men and women
who may be deployed in service of our
constitution and country
there exists the very real possibility
that the processing of their votes may
be delayed by the enactment of sb 418
and perhaps not counted on behalf of our
service men and women new americans and
those perhaps trying to exercise their
constitutional right to vote for the
first time i say that this bill is a
travesty i vehemently oppose this bill
and believe that its authors should be
ashamed for their thinly guised effort
to manipulate election results
close quote
thank you very much for allowing me the
opportunity to read on behalf of dr
keefner it's dr keithner it is
which is
k-i-e-f as in foxtrot n is in nancy er
great thank you
thank you madam chair
also signed up to speak on this bill is
uh matt muschien
mushien sorry i'm not doing very good on
names this morning
and you got it right the first time
great thank you
welcome
thank you
good morning madam chairwoman and
members of the house election law
committee my name is matt mushian i live
in claremont where i serve as a city
councilor
i also work with 603 ford a non-partisan
organization dedicated to
educating activating and empowering
young people in our state
which is why i'm here today to testify
in opposition to senate bill 418.
this bill creates confusion and
complicates our voting process which
will disproportionately burden the right
to vote for working age
and military voters who are also
predominantly younger
and that's why i urge the committee to
vote in expediting the legislate on
senate bill 418.
first and foremost this bill does
nothing to improve our elections and
it's rooted in conspiracy theories that
only serve to weaken faith in our
elections
in 2020 50
of working age voters aged 18 to 29
participated in the democratic process
and voted in the election
senate bill 418 seeks to only make it
harder for working age voters to
participate in the process by making
same-day voter registration
more difficult and burdensome
further this bill creates a provisional
ballot system for those registering to
vote for the first time on election day
which is again something that a lot of
young folks do if they've moved here for
work or for school
by implementing
this provisional ballot system as a
means to track someone's vote there are
also serious threats to ballot privacy
and security because
these provisional ballots would have a
unique number or identifier connecting
them to the name of a ballot at the name
of a voter meaning that in a small town
or a city like claremont your community
members who are working at the polls
could know who you voted for
also as this bill currently stands it
violates federal law that the uniformed
and overseas citizens absentee voting
act making it harder for military
members their families and other united
states citizens living out of the
country to vote
i have friends and family who have
served overseas and some currently do
and their service to our country should
be honored in the most basic possible
way by protecting their right to vote
and making sure that they are included
in our democracy no matter where they
are
these are just
some of the barriers that this
legislation creates for young people
exercising their constitutional right to
vote
this legislation creates unnecessary
confusion and complicates our voting
process as i said
and as a result voters may feel too
burdened to participate in the process
i've worked at my local polling location
before and i know that our election
officials work hard to keep our
elections safe and secure
and adding these additional needless and
confusing steps to our election day
operations will only burden local
election officials and confuse everyone
involved confusion leads to longer
alliance which are proven to
disenfranchise eligible voters
this body should be prioritizing making
it easier for people to participate in
the bedrock of our democracy free and
fair elections not creating unnecessary
burdens not so distrust in our elections
i ask you please devote an expedient to
legislate on senate bill 418 and i thank
you for your time and consideration
thank you for coming this afternoon any
questions
i'm seeing none thank you
also signed up to speak is kate horgan
thank you madam chair my name is kate
horgan i'm from the dupont group and
today i'm representing secure democracy
who is a non-partisan non-profit group
that is focused on voter integrity and
voter access they have extreme concerns
and you've had a lot of great speakers
so i will be very brief uh around the
ukava ballots just to walk through what
the process is so if this bill were in
place for this year
uh the ballots would have to go out 45
days before
the general election that would be
september 24th
this year the
primary is on the 13th
affidavit ballots wouldn't be finalized
until september 23rd and then the
secretary of state would have 14 days
after that primary meaning september
27th to finalize the elections i have
great faith in our secretary of state
however i do not know how if he's not
done until september 27th he can make
that uh september 24th deadline so we
just wanted to bring that to the
committee's attention
i'm happy to take any questions that the
committee has
but i will conclude my testimony at this
point matt and jer thank you miss horgan
any questions
from committee members i'm not saying
thank you thank you
also signed up in uh to speak on this is
henry
clementowitz from aclu
thank you madam chair and members of the
committee my name is henry clementowicz
i'm a senior staff attorney with the
american civil liberties union of new
hampshire
i submitted written testimony which
details in our view
the numerous legal problems with this
bill but in the interest of brevity i
thought i would just focus on two
the first concerns the documentary proof
of citizenship requirement
so
under this bill if a person registering
to vote for the first time on election
day does not have proof of citizenship
they'd be allowed to sign an affidavit
of then would have 10 days to provide
proof of citizenship to the secretary of
state's office before their or their
ballot would be
uncounted uh for most people who are
natural born citizens the only proof of
citizenship that exists is a u.s
passport or a birth certificate a
passport book costs 110 and takes 10 to
12 weeks to get
and a birth certificate depends uh
depending on the municipality of bert so
for an american born abroad to us
parents they need to send a notarized
request to the united states state
department and fifty dollars for someone
who's born in hawaii takes you know
probably five days to get mail to and
from hawaii so probably wouldn't have
time to get a birth certificate from
hawaii and submit it to the united uh to
the secretary of state to have their
vote counted um and the fact that it's
so hard to prove citizenship is probably
why
in 2020 the 10th circuit in a case
called fish versus schwab ruled as
unconstitutional kansas's similar effort
to require proof of documentary proof of
citizenship
to those who would vote the court
concluded in some we conclude that the
documentary
proof of citizenship requirement is
unconstitutional and uphold the district
court's injunction that decision was
affirmed when the u.s supreme court in
2020 declined to review it
just so we know how many people were
talking about in
2020 um
in the general election 816 people in
new hampshire used the qualify the
qualified voter affidavit to prove
citizenship so probably about that
number of people would be in danger of
having their votes discounted
if they did not return with the said
with a passport or a birth certificate
within 10 days
in addition
the process by which the moderators
would know how everyone who votes who
casts an absentee ballot
in my view violates the newest part of
the new hampshire constitution enacted
by the voters in 2018 which is part 1
article 2b
which provides an individual's right to
live free from governmental intrusion
and private or personal information is
natural essential and inherent
my view and the view of the aclu of new
hampshire is that the way that a person
voted is exactly the type
of private or personal information that
the electorate thought they were
enshrining constitutional protections
against governmental intrusion from
so um i think there's a number of issues
with this bill you've heard people talk
about you acaba you've heard people talk
about the the court decision from sp3 um
i'm happy to take any questions from the
committee but i did just want to uplift
one thing
i sent
late last evening a letter from the
attorney general's office to the
committee
indicating that
they do not have any criminal or civil
enforcement proceedings pending in
relation to wrongful voting stemming
from the september 8th 2020 or november
3rd 2020 elections
nor have they instituted any criminal or
civil enforcement proceedings at all
they had opened 23 investigations and 18
of those have been satisfactorily
resolved so there's five pending
investigations no even allegations
criminal or civil that anyone committed
any type of voter fraud in the 2020
elections so that's the type of state
interest that the state would have to
contend with in defending this law in
court the fact that the attorney
general's office has found no cases of
wrongful voting so i'm happy to take any
questions
if there
thank you do committee members have any
questions
seeing none thank you thank you also
signed up to speak on this bill is
michael o'brien
hello again madam chair members of the
committee my name is michael o'brien i
am with pretty strategies here today
representing america votes in opposition
to this bill
we've talked a lot already about some of
the points that i was going to make so
i'm going to skip over those and just
talk about a couple of
instances
of concern for me
so under this bill it specifies that a
first time
registrant in new hampshire would be the
one to fall under
sb 418 and the affidavit ballot however
it does not give any
example of how you would define or
figure out how a person is a first-time
new hampshire voter certainly on the
voter registration form we ask where
their previous registration was
and that form i suppose you could take
that voter at their word
and trust that they are in fact have
been registered in new hampshire before
um
but under this bill we are already
saying to people that we're not going to
take them at their word for filling out
a form so that seems a little
contradictory to begin with but secondly
what about the voter who voted
registered in new hampshire voted left
and now has come back their last
known voter registration may be in
massachusetts maybe
in hawaii maybe anywhere
that was not new hampshire how do we
figure out if that voter has in fact
registered in new hampshire before are
we going to ask them if we ask them when
they tell us are we going to believe
them what if the voter is wrong
as often happens if you ask local
election officials someone will attest
uh that they in fact have registered to
vote before and when they go into the
voter file that person is not there
often that is because the person has
come from a motor voter state and
assumes when they get their driver's
license that they
have automatically qualified to register
to vote and that is not the case um does
that person has that person violated the
law anyway i think these are procedural
questions that are real that have not
been addressed
i also think when you look back to 2016
you look at the number of individuals
who pull the domicile affidavit you can
see that over six thousand of them
pulled it as has been stated before
um
the so the sos secretary of state's
office was able to verify i think all
but 353 of those voters so i'm going to
be real generous here and say the sos
verified all but 353 within 10 days
right they get them all done within 10
days
the ag wasn't able to verify all but 66
and again they're not saying that 66
people committed fraud but that leaves
you with 290 voters
that basic maybe not quite but just
about whose ballots would have been
thrown away under this law and who were
legitimate voters found by the state to
be legitimate voters
that's the problem right we cannot be
should not be looking to throw away
legitimate votes and that would happen
under 418.
so in addition to all of the yokava
concerns that we have heard the privacy
concerns that we have heard um i just
wanted to point out two very specific
instances where this law runs into some
very serious trouble
and i'm happy to take any questions
thank you questions for mr o'brien
seeing none thanks thank you very much
also signed up to speak on this bill is
joe
magruder well i don't see but is he here
there he is
good afternoon
[Music]
chairwoman griffin and members of the
committee
uh
my microphone is on
my name is joe magruder i live in
concord
i am a longtime voter
and i am uh also from a military family
excuse me
and uh
spent four years in the navy uh
during uh
the latter part of the vietnam war
uh
i uh
i oppose strongly oppose uh senate bill
for a number of reasons uh that
others have mentioned
but in particular
the
deadline if you are
military deployed overseas the dead time
deadline in new hampshire as has already
been mentioned
uh makes it extremely hard
uh to
get a ballot fill it out absentee ballot
and send it back in
i was a connecticut voter when i was
serving but
i also have
letters
from two new hampshire veterans
who are
were unable to come today and i am going
to uh
tell you uh i will hand these in these
are the only copies i have so i can't
let go of them at the moment
uh
david catch
david cacciati c-a-c-c-i-o-t-t-i
hope i have that uh pronunciation right
uh is a
retired senior master sergeant uh in the
air force
22 years in the military
served overseas for 10 of those years
and
he
uh
strongly opposed the bill
opposes this bill
he says he and everyone he served with
uh uh took their right to vote seriously
and did vote when they were able to
uh
and uh were aware of and discussed being
under uh more time constraints than
their friends and family back home
our right to vote is sacred and no
not no more so than for military members
who are fighting to preserve that right
overseas
this bill does not successfully define
the logistics of ensuring ballot access
for overseas military personnel
making it near impossible for them to
get their ballots get them returned
uh in time to be
counted
uh quote this is unacceptable and
unconstitutional
i am here to ask you to vote no on
senate bill 418 to protect the right to
vote
to the military members of the military
members serving overseas
mr cacciati i've got to mention that is
from atkinson
the second letter
is
from bob baker also an air force veteran
lives in columbia new hampshire
i strongly believe that no americans
should have to fight for the right to
vote
especially true for the brave men and
women in uniform serving overseas
our right to vote is sacred and no more
so than for
deployed military
he
he obviously is against senate bill 418
which he says does not adequately
adequately protect the right to vote and
targets military members in particular
it makes it nearly impossible for
military personnel overseas
to get their ballots have them
uh returned on time and counted this is
an unconscionable violation of the right
to vote
when
and
quoting again when i served overseas
during the vietnam war i always tried to
vote sometimes the duty mission
prevented it i always felt badly about
missing the vote
i share that experience
please don't take away that voting right
from our new hampshire vets
or actually new new hampshire deployed
military is what he means obviously by
setting up completely unnecessary
restrictions on the exercise of our most
fundamental right
thank you mr magruder i you're way over
time but i know that you're reading
testimony from a couple of other people
all right
thank you for the opportunity to testify
and are you going to be able to submit
those letters to us yes i'm going to
okay if you want to give those to
representative murder we'll get them in
the record
great thank you thank you
also signed up to speak from nhma is mr
grace
thank you madam chair h grace from the
new hampshire municipal association
um we don't oppose efforts to ensure
voters provide proper identification and
documentation but we are concerned about
the process set up by this bill you've
already heard from a number of municipal
officials today i won't reiterate
anything that they said um suffice to
say they they
we've heard the same concerns
at nhma
um the only additional uh thing i'd like
to add is that
one concern that that came to our
attention was
um from those officials who
uh election officials who stand next to
the
ballot counting device there was a
concern from a number of municipalities
that
you know they would have to engage in a
dialogue with a voter other than
put in your ballot any way you want
because these the process set up by this
bill would require the voter after
voting to put the
the affidavit ballot into a side pocket
obviously
that could result in some
confident confrontation depending on how
the voter takes that and how they
understand a lot of work
with that
i don't want to prolong this hearing any
longer than necessary so i'm happy to
take any questions that committee has
any questions
i'm not seeing any thank you
also signed up to speak is liz
tentarelli
thank you for this opportunity to speak
my name is liz tenterelli i'm president
of the league of women voters of new
hampshire
we're a non-partisan organization
whose mission is to empower voters
and we do that in many ways one of them
is to prepare brochures
that are distributed it's it's online
we're distributed at all sorts of places
and to all sorts of groups we also do
presentations
about the voting process
and about two months ago i was talking
to a group of people called the granite
leaders
these are formerly homeless people
who are being taught to find their civic
voices and use it to advocate for those
who are still homeless
and they had lots of questions about
voting as you can imagine
they were very surprised with when i
told them that you don't need a driver's
license to prove identity that you can
get a non-driver's id from the dmv and
we talked about that of course one of
them said so how do i get to the dmv
well you know good point we have to find
a better way to do that
but they want to vote
they may not have the documents that are
required in here
so i started looking at it from that
point of view
our documents that are our flyers and so
on that we produce are getting more and
more complicated every year
as the legislature passes one law after
another
trying to chase away that phantom of the
white vans from massachusetts bringing
up voters illegally on election day the
laws get more complicated
not for you and me we understand what
these laws are
but for the average voter this threatens
to make those eligible voters not vote
so on the second page of my testimony
i admit i had a little fun
i tried to imagine what the document
would look like
that would be given to this person who
did not show up with a voter id for
instance
or did not have citizenship papers
now unlike sb3 where everything was
spelled out and that was one of the
reasons it was defeated because the
language was way way way too confusing
i tried to imagine here
since it's not in the bill what the
language would look like so you see that
in the box on page two
and
it might look something like this it's
not even complete i said here i expect
you'll put in this language that
language
the point i am trying to make is
the average person coming in to vote
maybe for the first time maybe an 18
year old is simply not used to reading
this
imagine being handed this by the
supervisor of the checklist and saying
you've got 10 days to fill out this form
and get a copy of whatever is checked
off there and mail it back in this
envelope which by the way costs 27 and
we don't know if it's the city town or
the state who pays for that
and then they walk out and they said but
i already voted
so why do i do this
that kind of confusion
is what we need to avoid in order to
restore the public's faith in elections
i don't think our faith has been
destroyed
but it's teetering and the more
complicated the process gets the worse
it is
for people to feel that they have the
power to exercise their right to vote
i'm going to leave these brochures which
are dated 2021 but there's
still applicable we haven't changed the
law since then in case anybody wants to
pick one up on the way out so thank you
very much for your attention if you have
questions i'm glad to answer them thank
you very much i'm impressed you got the
box done in the middle of the text i
can't do that anymore
for liz tentarelli
seeing none thank you
uh will hopkins has signed up to provide
us some input on this bill
i thank you so much for giving me a
little bit of time i won't take much of
it um i was born in plymouth grew up in
plymouth
i lived a year in concord i've lived
in belmont for the last 10 years but
i've always called new hampshire home
with the exception of
2004-2005 when i was in iraq as a u.s
army infantryman
that
i voted absentee um
and i i wanted to make sure that i came
in to ask the committee to vote in
expedia to legislate on this
um in particular i know that that there
are
um provisions that suggest that you
could print out a ballot or do
online ballots
um the post when you're in a combat zone
is extremely unreliable can take a
couple weeks i was lucky enough to be
stationed on a major life support area
lsa anaconda um but for folks on forward
operating bases mail could take
several weeks to get get in and out
so that the timeliness factor is
definitely important we had one printer
for our company i certainly was not
allowed to use it it was in the supply
sergeant's office and
i'm so printing something off is not
possible internet access in particular
on forward operating bases can't happen
um so the timing here means that this
would this would almost certainly uh
disenfranchise folks who are um in
combat zones and i just wanted to make
sure as somebody who has experienced
voting from a combat zone
um that that this bill really shouldn't
be something that we're looking at
seriously so thank you for your time
thank you very much for coming
does anybody have any questions
thanks so much
i also have um someone from the
secretary of state's office signed up to
speak on this i actually have david
scanlon signed up but i haven't seen him
is he here oh look at that i didn't even
make you out there um and then following
that um senator gaida who is the prime
sponsor of the bill has asked to speak
last i have no other pink cards on 418
so if you want to speak on 418 please
all right
hold on secretary
your name ma'am
oh all right i thought
sorry i when i took when i left for a
minute i think i thought you had spoken
so
we'll go to you next and
um
then senator gaida and just since
senator gray is here that the people i
do need pink cards from are the two
senators so thank you
all right
because you did introduce it senator
gray all right welcome secretary scan
thank you madam chair members of the
committee i'm david scanlan secretary of
state and i will say senator guide is
braver than i to be between the
committee and the cafeteria at this time
of day so yeah um
i'm here in in general support of senate
bill 418
uh
and the efforts that senator guida has
undertaken with
along with uh others
um
secretary gardner and i had worked with
senator guida
last fall on on his ideas
and i think that
you know he is addressing
an area that is probably the greatest
threat to our
elections
uh moving forward and that is
a serious decline in voter confidence
we're seeing it in new hampshire but
we're also seeing it nationally
there's a number of reasons for that
but the bottom line is that we have to
take steps
to make sure that the voters that
participate in new hampshire elections
feel that the elections are
fair
their votes are being accurately counted
and that those individuals that are
participating in the election are
qualified to participate
and that's what this bill attempts to
get at
our system in new hampshire is based on
a series a set of checks and balances
we see it in the polling place by the
elected locally elected officials that
work there
we also see
partisan participation in the fact that
the political parties get to submit
names for individuals to serve as ballot
clerks
and also individuals that can serve as
challengers in the election
and in the voting process itself there
is a natural tension that exists between
ease of voting
and making sure that those individuals
that are voting are qualified to vote
and i will say and i think everybody in
this room should agree that it is
extremely easy to vote in new hampshire
and i would argue that if we're not the
easiest state to participate in an
election we're pretty darn close
we're also seeing although it hasn't
been reflected in testimony today
that there is a growing sense in many
voters
that there are
problems with the election that there is
fraudulent voting that takes place or it
is easy to allow that happen
and they believe that even if it's just
a perception you know they believe that
perception
uh you know i will say very openly and
clearly i don't agree with that position
you know
voting in new hampshire is fair i
believe the results are accurate
there are isolated instances of
inappropriate voting and the attorney
general's office has made prosecutions
along those lines in recent years
but there is nothing that appears to be
organized or widespread
so that gets back to senator guida's
bill senate bill 418
and it it tries to address
the security side of the voting process
trying to take some steps
that will let
other voters see
that
those that are participating in the
election are qualified
this is not the end-all there's many
other things that we have to do and
as the secretary of state we have plans
this
summer and fall
to
be very visible we want to have an open
discussion about these issues
we want to do a lot more related to
voter education on the on this process
of voting
and we're also going to do a lot more
work with local election officials
on training uh
focusing on transparency this process
has to be as transparent as we can make
it
every step of the way
and while i generally support the
efforts
of this legislation
i believe that there are constitutional
questions that need to be addressed
um i i would like to see this bill
amended you know to address
some of the other concerns that have
been mentioned
but there is a tool the legislature has
to lay a bill like this on the table
send a resolution to the supreme court
and ask them for
an
advisory opinion on those questions
that they would like to ask and some of
those uh you know i would start off
by asking if part two article 32 of the
constitution
requires that all ballots
that are cast in an election
be counted with the results declared
in one continuous meeting in other words
you know when the polls close
do all the results have to be
accounted for at that time
or is there any scenario where vote
tallies from ballots not counted on the
day the election
can be added to the declared results
announced on election day
and that's a question directly related
to provisional ballots
which is something by the way that is
used in just about every other state in
the country new hampshire is unique
in that all ballots are cast in election
are counted on the day of the election
and there is no provisional ballot
process
similarly is there any scenario where
vote tallies can be subtracted from the
declaration of results after the
election
that were counted on the day the
and that is specific to this novel
version of a provisional ballot where
as it's called an affidavit ballot in
the bill would be counted on the day of
the election
but if the voter did not respond to the
request for
uh
documentation then their the votes on
their ballot would be
discounted from
the election some days after took place
and then does providing
does requiring a voter to provide
documentation qualifications
after having voted on the daily election
constitute a burden as was determined by
the court in senate bill 3.
there is also the question that was
raised today about uh the uocaba ballots
and those absentee ballots that are sent
to our military
and overseas personnel
i can tell you that there is no desire
on my part or the part of
the secretary of state's office to
not meet that 45-day deadline and in
fact if we did not uh meet it then
uh the u.s department of justice would
be all over us in in very short order
and certainly that's an experience that
none of us want
um
you know there are ways to deal with
that time frame you know you could
shorten it up and give a voter fewer
days
to
comply with a request for documentation
there's a pending bill before the
legislature to move the date of the
state primary
uh although i'm not advocating for that
my position is that
the
state primary is fine just the way it is
um
i will stop there madam chair uh and i
will be happy to answer any questions
questions for secretary scanlon
representative bergeron
thank you madam chair thank you
secretary scanlon um
a small constitutional question 28a
an earlier speaker said that there were
about 6 000 affidavits used in the 2016
election i thought it was closer to
7 500 but be that as it may the postage
cost for that many affidavits would then
run between 160 000 to 200 and 2 000 and
i'm sure would have to be more because
the polling sites would have to have
more envelopes than they would possibly
need uh there's no fiscal note in this
and it doesn't say who's going to be
responsible for those exorbitant postage
prices is it your intent that this is
going to be taken up by the secretary of
state you're going to write it out of
your budget
that was my understanding the way i read
the bill is that the secretary of state
is supposed to provide
the packets that would be issued to a
voter
that was voting by an affidavit ballot
with prepaid
overnight postage
on those documents
we're working on refining the fiscal
note in fact i think patty lovejoy has
been working on that
um and uh you know we should have a
figure for you that is uh been hundreds
of thousands of dollars okay thank you
thank you further questions
representative muirhead thank you madam
chair thank you mr secretary
um i have a uh two two quick questions
please
one is uh some earlier witnesses
testified that they were concerned that
this passage of this bill might cause
the state to lose its exemption
to the national voter registration act
and putting to the side the prediction
of whether that might happen would
anything important to new hampshire
citizens be lost
if the state were to lose its exemption
to the national voter registration act
we have developed a unique election
process over time that works incredibly
well
i would not want to see us lose our
exemption to the national voter
registration act
i i really want to see the
you know the analysis that the prior
testimony
has that would suggest that that might
happen
uh i'm not convinced at this point that
it would
thank you actually i'll just stop there
thank you for coming
thank you further questions
representative hamer
thank you um
how confident are you with the voter's
privacy is kept private
where
the mythology the bill established
affidavit balloting for voters and the
affidavit balloting would include a
ballot in a different color other than
the ballot
and it would contain a serialized
tear-off strip and will require local
election officials to mail the strips to
the secretary of state
i i'm
finding this is kind of
not keeping the privacy we're very
concerned about the privacy i believe
what you just read was from the original
bill
and as amended by the senate that that
language is no longer there okay thank
you
yeah just for clarification it the bill
you're looking at should be
as amended by the senate
representative terezian
thank you madam chair thank you
secretary skill i'm taking the question
i just want to clarify a little bit on
what you said in regard to because
there's a lot of questions on
you cover and the military vote
do you believe the bill could be um
amended to satisfy that notwithstanding
moving the primary date
we would have to get creative and how
that would happen uh but there is no
question that there is a federal
deadline uh under the uh
both java and the federal move act that
absentee ballots to military and
overseas personnel have to be out no
later
than 45 days before the election
uh the bill allows us it's the only uh
it's no longer the only opportunity to
email ballots to
voters but for you okava voters we can
actually email their ballot to them they
then then have to download it mark it
and then send it back
through some type of mail service
there is a provision now that
is that also exists for uh individuals
with print disabilities to take
advantage of the same type of
email balloting
representative hayward
thank you madam chair and uh thank you
mr secretary uh that
i'm glad that you
brought that up uh the point
uh about whether
electronic means were available under
yukaba
has been
uh overlooked up until this time
and uh um
so uh i'm glad that you uh mentioned
that
thank you
representative barry yes um thank you mr
secretary you said in your uh testimony
something that i've pondered many times
before
which is about the requirement that new
hampshire's ballots be counted on
election night which stems from the fact
that the moderator has to announce the
results in one continuous meeting um can
you elaborate at all on because i've had
the same thought it doesn't actually
says it doesn't actually say it has to
be counted that night it just says one
continuous meeting can you elaborate on
how that would work with this bill if we
were not if we were to implement this
and how it could be compliant with the
new hampshire constitution
well i i i have a question in my own
mind whether
uh you know we can
have some type of a provisional ballot
whether it's an affidavit ballot or a
true provisional ballot and then and
then deal with
uh adding or subtracting
votes to the overall total after the
you know some days after the election
and i think that
based on the way that that provision in
the constitution is written it would
require
an interpretation
follow-up
so and when we do a recount are we how
does a recount factor in with
that part of the constitution because we
are changing recounts can change
election results they rarely do um but
they could they most certainly change
that not election outcomes election
results um so how does how does that
work is it it seems to me like we've
already are kind of i don't want to say
violating that but are passed it if you
will
the recount is only a votes that were
cast in the election
and so it's just it's verifying account
but it is not adding additional
votes or subtracting additional
i should say it's not adding
we're subtracting additional ballots
that were not counted on the day of the
election
just if before so to clarify you're
distinguishing between the counting of
ballots and the actual total yes
okay
representative tillerson
thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my question i'm just wondering if
you could um comment with your thoughts
on how
the uh the 10-day time period after uh
election day how that could potentially
affect our
position as first in the nation for the
presidential primary
i don't think it really would impact
that i mean if we if we're talking about
you know counting
or subtracting votes
i don't know that there would be that
many uh affidavit ballots that would
affect the outcome of a presidential
presidential primary
um you know i i suppose there's an
outside possibility that could but i
think that
generally speaking the margins are such
that you know there's usually a clear
winner
of the of the new hampshire primary
follow-up
so you don't think
the um the view from other parties
looking in on new hampshire would
question uh the validity in case we did
have a close
close primary
well i i don't think that the that an
affidavit
type out or let's just say it's a
provisional ballot uh would make that
much of a difference because every other
state is operating under the same sort
of sort you know same set of
uh conditions most other states have a
provisional ballot
that if the qualifications of a voter
are in doubt on the day of the election
the voter gets to vote a provisional
ballot and that ballot is counted
if it makes a difference in the outcome
and only after those qualifications have
been proven in another state and
um you know i think the the presidential
primary the results are going to be
announced at the end of the night you
know that's going to be the winner um
you know i don't know how much of an
impact
you know adding or subtracting
some votes
subsequent to that is going to affect
the outcome of you know that process
further questions representative baum
thank you madam chair thank you for
taking the question
so the only really the only problem we
have
with these quote
affidavit ballots is on primary
for the 45 days every other election we
don't do not have that problem is that
correct
that's right the the when we're sending
after we prepare the ballots for the
for the primary election whether it's
the presidential or the state there's
more than enough time
to get the absentee ballots out to
military and overseas citizens it's just
that tight time frame between
our state primary and the general
election that creates an issue
further questions representative
wilhelms
thank you madam chair and thank you
secretary for taking the question um
would you agree with uh the governor's
statement earlier this week that 99 of
granite staters uh have confidence in
our elections
uh i would say that that a few years ago
uh there were some polls that reflected
that however more recently
the polling is suggesting that that that
that statistic is is shaken and
and as i mentioned before there's a
number of reasons for that it's rhetoric
at the national level um
you know there's statements being made
from you know the left and the right
that that uh you know put doubt in
voters minds and
and social media you know is playing a
big role in that as well and you know
the trick is how do we how do we put the
brakes on that and convince our voting
population that
nothing has changed our you know our
elections are
just as sound today as they were 20
years ago
thank
you thank you any other questions
representative hamer
thank you um
people registering to vote on election
day
for the first time in new hampshire
would be given an affidavit ballot
provisional ballot
if they don't have proof of citizenship
or domicile do supervisors of the
checklist at the polls know whether a
prudential registrant has ever been
registered in new hampshire before
it's probably a better question to ask
you know one of the local election
officials but um
it may depend on whether they have
direct access to election net
you know which is the statewide
centralized database
i'm sure they could look a voter up to
see
if they had voted elsewhere in new
hampshire
there's still many polling places that
don't have the connectivity at the
polling place itself and i would expect
that that might be a tough thing to do
further question follow up
so how would you handle senate bill 418
when it affects a voter who comes into
the polls on election day
and says he's just bought a new home in
a different ward
in manchester he sold his other home in
the other ward
he's voted all his lifetime
so he's um
he's a new voter
or
would he be subject to this provisional
ballot
affidavit ballot
yeah i don't have the answer to that uh
at the moment but i'd be happy to think
about it and get back to you
thank you
representative wilhelm
thanks madam chair and thank you
secretary for taking the question um
so someone from the brennan center
shared what some of the additional
expenses might be um
if we were to implement uh senate bill
418 one of the things she talked about
was adding temporary staff on election
day um
i'm just having a tough time wrapping my
head around all the expenses
that would be required if this bill
becomes law
what
what are your thoughts on
what those expenses would be
because the fiscal note just isn't
helpful could you just kind of break it
down for us and including temporary
stuff i'd be happy to let me let me not
do that at the moment but we'll get the
work that we've been doing to you very
quickly so that you can see the numbers
that
we've been working on okay
the the the numbers
that were expressed by the brennan
center about what it would cost to
uh
have to comply with the national voter
registration act are consistent with
what my belief is in terms of those
costs okay great thank you further
questions from committee members
all right seeing none thank you thank
you secretary scanlan um also signed up
to speak on this and i apologize for
putting you in the already spoken file
judy strachelastus
come on up all right so everybody
understands what the intent of this
chair is this hearing has gone wrong i
knew this would be a long hearing but it
has gone longer than i thought um and
this meeting has to be over by two for
the chair so we are not breaking keep
that in mind for yourselves
we are going straight through
i have one more two more people after
this person three more
um two more after this uh representative
moffatt wants to speak to this bill and
senator geider the prime sponsor is here
to speak to it it is my intent to close
the public hearing at that time we have
noticed exact session
given the time and the fact that there
are amendments flying around
um i don't we are not going to exec all
the bills that i had hoped to exec
however given that we have
members
six members who have driven here today
because your chair said we were going to
exec we will exec one bill
um and it will be 364. so after this
hearing we're going right into an exact
on 364
um and then we will be breaking for the
day so thank you for indulgence if
people need to take a walk because we're
probably going to be here for another
15-20 minutes uh if you need to take a
walk down the hall this might be a good
time so having said that i apologize for
taking you literally to my sort of
snapshot of the end of the day and
welcome for you to us thank you
um my name is thank you uh chairman
griffin and representatives i'm a
supervisor of the checklist in derry i'm
just beginning my third term and jerry
is the largest has the largest voters
checklist in the state
so i
i'm happy to answer procedural questions
for
for anybody i i submitted written
testimony because i didn't think i could
be here this this afternoon
so i hope you'll read that but
i just wanted to talk about some
questions that have been raised by other
speakers and
points that haven't already been made
the first thing is that i in
in my experience
sb 418 will affect a far higher number
than is being anticipated
because
mr clementowitz mentioned 816 people
use citizenship affidavits in 2020.
that's only what's recorded in the state
database
nearly everyone who completes a
citizenship affidavit is not entered in
the database
because the database only allows us to
flat flag a checkbox
for
qualified voter affidavit for
citizenship
if the person was
born outside the u.s most of the people
born outside the u.s became naturalized
citizens and they are aware of the
they're going to be asked to establish
citizenship and they generally tend to
bring
um
documents with them a passport or a
naturalization certificate
it's the
people um that are born in the u.s that
are more likely to fill it out so
the database can easily be reprogrammed
to allow us to flag them but the problem
is that
the estimates based on what's in the
system now are grossly inadequate
in derry we have 2 200 people registered
to vote on a non-coven presidential
election half at least half of those
people will complete a citizenship
affidavit it only exists in paper form
in the files in
town offices around the state
so
derry would have 1100 alone
that would need solely for citizenship
domicile is easy to
establish
people carry the license or other id
around in their wallet
um
same with identity but citizenship is
not something people carry around with
them or keep handy
as other speakers mentioned and realize
real id does not apply social security
card doesn't establish it military id
doesn't establish it
so
so i think that the costs
will will be much higher at twenty seven
dollars
per envelope
than anticipated
the number of the number of affidavit
ballots
will therefore will also exceed the
margins of victory
meaning that most
races in many in most towns
will be in limbo for for two to three
weeks um
and
that affects the ability of
to get for the town clerks to get out
over military and overseas ballots
and it will also negatively affect
public confidence in the integrity of
elections when the results change
and also people want people
people want news immediately
when it takes longer
people think this fraud
um
some
mr o'brien brought up
for the explanation for first-time
voters and uh
secretary scanlan mentioned that also
the way that
the current law is in
sb 418 would be the same
it
exempts voters who have previously
registered in new hampshire
that
the way to tell that is to look them up
in the in the database but we have three
supervisors of the checklist in derry
and with 2200 people we're not look we
don't have time only the only the three
elected supervisors are able to look
that information up
even if we have
laptops and a secure connection and a
reliable connection
there's no way that we could
ever look up 1100 people
we have between 24 to 36
assistant supervisors helping people on
election day and they they can't funnel
all those people in to see three people
at the end
um so what we do
is
we require everyone since it's a
constitutional requirement to prove
citizenship even if they list they were
born in the u.s
we require them to fill out a qualified
voter affidavit for citizenship
thank you you're i just if you've got
okay yeah i
i think that this defeats voter id okay
because it allows the supervisors of the
checklist to verify the identity of
voters who don't possess a photo id
when they check in
that that presumably would mean
us looking people up in the in the voter
list there's not all that many people
that don't have an id so that's not the
issue the issue is
there's nothing in the voter id that
would prevent somebody from voting in
the name of a recently
said there's not
nothing
that process
means that the per
allowing supervisors to identify someone
through the voter checklist means that
that person is not didn't present a
photograph and is not photographed as
part of an affidavit process
the voter records don't contain
photographs
and all the information that's in there
the non-public information
is generally available in obituaries so
anybody who recently died
is
their obituary is going to have the date
of birth where they were born the kind
of questions that the supervisors could
ask is publicly available
so
i so i pose on that grounds and
let's see
one other thing that would need to be
clarified if this passes is that
supervisors of the checklist cannot
touch ballots we couldn't hand affidavit
ballots to people
affidavit ballot
packets
to people and we can't
instruct people on how to how to
complete the voting process
so that right now it says authorized
election official and that should be
clarified
thank you
thank you very much and thanks for
waiting all morning is are there any
questions
oh i'm sorry no that's okay you can you
can get away
uh representative moffitt did you want
to speak
thank you madam sheriff for indulging me
i had not planned to speak i'll take a
minute or less i just wanted to follow
up on the secretary of state's uh
comments by just quickly sharing that i
had a state rep i am a state rep by the
way for the record uh mike moffat
merrimack district 9 canterbury and
loudoun
i did have a state rep race years ago
that ended in a tie
a tie
so obviously there was a recount and on
the recount i dropped one vote on the
recount
so i just wanted to underscore that
every vote counts uh in my case uh
later on some folks looked into same-day
registrants uh some of the same-day
registrants uh could not be tracked down
they may have voted for me we don't know
so that's less than minutes all i wanted
to say was every vote counts and efforts
to ensure uh the integrity of our
elections i think need full uh
consideration thank you
madam chair and i'll take questions if
are
any questions for representative moffat
thank you thank you
all right and then
and then we have senator gaida i have
nobody else signed up to speak on this
so the sponsor usually goes first so
this is i think maybe my first hearing
where the sponsor is actually going last
so welcome to senator guida thank you
madam chair for the record senator bob
guy to district 2 prime sponsor on
senate bill 418.
i appreciate the committee's indulgence
in allowing me to speak after the
commencement of the hearing
i was at a medical appointment as the
saying goes
growing old is not for sissies
the right to vote
is not
an unqualified right
it is a qualified right
and we as a legislator are
constitutionally empowered to establish
those qualifications
every living breathing person on the
planet is not entitled to vote
in new hampshire but under current law
any living breathing person on the
planet can come here and vote
think about that
i can come here i sign a paper that says
i'm a citizen or i live here okay
we've had over two and a half million
people come across the southern border
the united states
in the last few years and more are
coming
how do we know
whether or not they're here voting we
don't
with the affidavit system a person
vouches that i am who i am i live where
i live i am a citizen whatever the case
may be
but the follow-up
is irrelevant
why do i say that
the follow-up is irrelevant because
by the time
the 60-day window has expired for the
secretary of state to deliver the
questionable ballots
to the attorney general and by the time
the attorney general is completed with
the investigation
the vote has already been counted cast
and certified that's the loophole that
we're trying to close
bill stops no one from voting
it creates no new restrictions
it says within the existing
qualifications already established in
law
you who have failed as a citizen in your
civic duty to meet the obligation to
qualify to vote
we're giving you an extra 10 days and
telling you what it is you need to
provide
and i do that to protect the sanctity of
the vote not to exclude anyone i don't
target college kids i don't target
immigrants i target
qualified voters
it is not an unqualified right
if you look at the notes
in the preamble if you will the findings
okay on average
basically one race a year is won or lost
by a vote
when you go to look at the number by two
or three or five the number goes up very
significantly
this data was given to me by bill
gardner
bill and myself secretary scanlon
worked very hard on this bill as did
senator i'm sorry representative former
justice bob lynn
i told representative lin put your
justice hat on and rip this to shreds
senator you may not know what he's
walked in the room
i asked him i
i don't i don't say i won't care i said
i'm not concerned
okay and so
um
again
this bill is attempting to close a
gaping loophole
okay and when people say that
establishing this process which
increases nothing except if you show up
you sign an affidavit you get a document
that says with an envelope paid by the
state you need to return the proof of
that qualification that you claim you
have
not doing that
renders our system vulnerable
and dishonors the service of the
millions who have given their lives to
protect the sanctity of the vote
the sanctity of the qualified vote the
sanctity of the citizens vote
not the sanctity of the vote of any
living breathing human being
we are it's a qualified vote
with respect to the military
i served in the marine corps i served
during vietnam i served subsidies to
that i served my country as an fbi agent
my son is in the navy as an officer at
this time my wife was a navy nurse to
those that might insinuate or imply that
anything in this bill ever intended
to deny the right to vote to the
military
i reject that assertion i will say
that
there is a bill before you senate bill
that will move the primary back to
august it was you it was voted on you i
won't see unanimous bipartisan in the
senate it is before you now
and there's a reason for that doing so
enables our federal candidates to have
access to much more of the funding
available which is gone by the time our
primary in september is closed
there's a reason for this
all right you'll deliberate that bill in
concert with this
we don't have
an overseas military ballot problem
so again
it's not an unqualified vote
the process is not difficult
you won't have any longer lines than you
have now
and yes
i'm going to require someone that says
believe me
i'm a u.s citizen believe me i live here
and can't produce any of the list of
documents provided to prove residency
right
we're gonna say okay we believe you
your vote will be counted but it will
not be certified certification of the
ballots right now in the house and the
senate
is a ceremonial process
secretary of state comes in the
president's senate picks three people
they go out yeah yeah they come back in
it's certified this gives meaning
to the certification of that ballot
it protects the sanctity
of the right of qualified citizens of
the united states to vote
and it protects the sanctity of the vote
of every new hampshire resident in
casabella thank you madam chair i'll
take any questions thank you senator
questions for the senator representative
bergeron thank you madam chair thank you
senator um
let me start with one question about
process page 2 lines
22-24
it states that no later than one day
after the election the moderator shall
forward all affidavit ballot
verification letters to the secretary of
state using a secure means of
transmission or delivery
there's really two questions here first
part
all the return of votes forms are
returned to the secretary of state by
the clerk on election night why in this
case is are these forms being held on
by the moderator to return them up to a
day later
thank you for your question the reason
we worded it that way that does not
preclude those documents from going
with the certification okay that sent
the day of the election it just gives
them an extra day in case perhaps
something got misplaced or they wanted
to verify but it doesn't preclude them
going at the same time it just says well
you've got an extra day if you need it
okay further question i'm sure follow up
uh and and this is
kind of a question i asked at the
beginning of this hearing hours ago
um
given
that the state
spent almost four million dollars
litigating senate b
senate bill 3
and given that there was a
federal court decision in 2020 fish
versus schwab in in kansas which ruled
that the requirement for documentary
proof of citizenship was a violation of
the 14th amendment under the equal
protection clause
why didn't the senate uh
take the secretary of state's
advice or suggestion
that uh our supreme court be asked for
an opinion on the constitutionality of
this bill
well i will share this with you
there have been three decisions in the
nation made by the us supreme court
which is irrelevant let me strike that
remark
um
we opted not to do it because
i don't believe that we should
subordinate our
laws that are proposed
to the opinions of justices who since
they're not in law
what we send to them can be taken apart
based on whatever it is they choose to
say
i don't believe we as a legislative
branch subordinate our opinions
our actions to the courts
constitution says are separate and equal
let's keep it that way i thought about
this question
and i signify specifically said i will
not
subordinate this this is an issue
of of the sanctity of the vote
okay and to say that
we're going to ask the court's mother
may i
i won't do that i just will not do that
i have no further questions further
questions from the committee
representative boehm
thank you madam chairman thank you
senator gaiden kinda uh wouldn't this
bill also say that make sure that my
vote will not be overwritten by somebody
else's vote
your question is quite correct your
answer is quite correct in a way um
and it's true we're here to protect the
sanctity of each vote
it's in the sanctity of the qualified
voters ballots
not the sanctity of those unqualified
note for the record i didn't say fraud i
didn't say theft i said unqualified
and that's what we must assure as
carrying the trust of the people of the
state
further questions from committee members
oh i'm sorry representative murad i had
you down and forgot go ahead thank you
man
thank you senator
um
my understanding is that someone who
registers to vote 30 days or more in
advance of an election
well everybody has to prove four things
as you know senator citizenship
age domicile and identity
and voters registering more than 30 days
in advance of an election can prove
citizenship by signing a sworn statement
on the voter registration form
as i read the bill it looks like
voters registering day of
will need to produce a passport
or a birth certificate or not
naturalization papers
is the intention of the bill to create
two classes of voters
excellent question thank you uh no it is
not and i focus exclusively on looking
very hard at same day registrants people
that come up the day of the election you
got two years between elections to
register and and produce documentation
um what we're looking at is
to ensure that the last minute person
that comes up
is in fact qualified to vote and it is
no way intended to create a dual class
if you will on the right on the uh
qualification for citizenship
yeah i have a follow-up on the
citizenship question uh madam chair on
the city on the
type of fraud that you know passport or
um
birth certificate
or uh naturalization papers would guard
against which is someone voting who's
not a citizen of the united states as
opposed to say someone voting in two
different states or something who is a
citizen
do well do you know of how many people
have been
located or convicted of
having voted in new hampshire who have
it turns out not been citizens of the
united states in
some window of time like the last 10 or
20 years
don't know and i don't believe we have
the data we have no way of knowing
so
include a hundred to the thousand
possibly could zero possibly
again uh what we're trying to do is
close this loophole this gaping hole in
our in the integrity of our elections
and and the quality of our elections and
the process is not it's not a question
here we have an excellent process
but
the gatekeeping for that process is
what's lacking
once you're into our system it works
fabulously i've been moderating just
finished as a moderator for my town for
eight years
the system works great we have great
officials we've got great volunteers and
a good process but
the entry into that system
is what is the vulnerability to its
integrity
thank you senator thank you sir further
questions
oh thank you representative
thank you thank you for taking my
question senator um i'm curious about
what we heard earlier about um a
potential conflict with part one article
2b
uh the right to privacy and having our
information protected um would you agree
that
one's ballot and how they vote would
fall under that uh part of our
conference absolutely i would also state
that
there's no more disclosure of personal
voting information in this
than there is with the opening of
absentee ballots by a moderator
moderator handles a ballot it's marked
okay so
what we did in this bill is we
structured very carefully all the
processes in here mirror already
existing processes in state law for
particular election
components
and again that was one with with the
help of the secretary of state that was
with the help of some volunteers
uh and uh
and so i don't think there is that
threat
okay the ballots are never named they're
numbered and the moderator does that now
um they're separately placed because
once you mark a ballot you run the risk
of messing up a machine that might read
it so they're put in hand counted all
right
so people that we trust
the moderator
are the ones that would see
what was on a ballot if he or she chose
to look and no moderator that i know
would do that we respect
fully the right to privacy that ballot
just a very quick thank you we we heard
earlier today about a
town election where there was one
challenge voter affidavit david and it
seems to me in small town and we have a
lot of small towns in new hampshire that
anyone who was voting who was in there
and saw someone walk out with one of
those folders and then saw a change in
the totals ten days later would be able
to put two and two together um you don't
feel that that's a violation of that
person's privacy
did you restate that question
sorry
we we heard uh anecdote about i believe
it was milford the town of milford uh
the most recent election they had one
person that had to sign a challenge vote
after david and if this bill were to
become law they would have walked out
with their
27 prepaid envelope to return the
secretary of state's office and if
another voter
uh was in the proc in the area not
necessarily an election official and saw
their neighbor john doe walking out with
that envelope
wouldn't you think that um 10 days later
if they then saw in milford that
certain races all dropped by one vote
that perhaps they would know that their
neighbor john doe voted for
these different candidates if the total
drop by one vote is because the person
that voted was not qualified to vote and
thereby violated the law
and so the question then becomes
do they have the right to privacy of
that ballot since it's going to go to
court if the system works as it's
supposed to it's not going to be private
knowledge anymore
thank you representative bergeron
um thank you madam chairman just a
follow-up question to your response to
the representative's question
you said if that person's vote was
disqualified because the voter was
not eligible to vote isn't it true that
it's just that the voter didn't return
the required documentation he may have
been certainly eligible to vote
it was just the paperwork was eligible
but not qualified according to the
constitution and the laws of this state
and that is what we are sworn to uphold
i come back to the point that qualified
voter
not any voter it's a qualified right
it's not an unqualified right
and for that reason a person does not
produce those qualifications that ballot
is invalid it's not fraudulent fraud
goes to intent
it's invalid it's unqualified the vote
needs to be subtracted
this is not a provisional ballot i'll
throw that in because the provisional
ballot doesn't count the vote until the
certificate until the qualification is
proven by the voter
in this case we're counting it because
the constitution requires that or that's
been the interpretation but we're going
to then say well well secretary of state
gets a document that's required it's
over
it doesn't get the document it's
required
an email goes up or letter goes up to
the town
and they then will send the number and
the doc and the verification letter with
the um with the ballot will then go to
the attorney general for their their
deal you know for their taking care of
uh potential prosecution
thank you
further questions from the committee
seeing none thank you thank you for
spending a bit of the morning and
afternoon with us senator thank you
madam chair members of the committee
that concludes the public hearing on sb
i want to thank everybody for
participating in the hearing this
morning
um
everybody was good we stuck to times and
at this time i am going to
open the executive session in the
election law we had four bills that i
hope to get to today um there are a
couple of amendments one of which i
haven't even seen yet so
we are going to be back here next week
with executive session
um
and we will try to address as many bills
as we can then but having said that we
also there is one bill that i'm
thinking we might have a pretty good
result out of this committee and that is
sb 364.
um
sb 364 was relating to electronic poll
books
it had a public hearing on april 6
the sponsor of this was senator perkins
cochran
and um
does anybody have a motion on this bill
yes uh i have a motion i
representative prudhomme o'brien
my move ought to pass on this bill
is there a second madam cheryl second
it's second by representative bergeron
is there any further discussion on this
bill
uh i would i would explain
thank you representative uh this bill is
a very simple bill that uh
changes the requirement that paper
backups
of
electronic poll books are completed in
10 minutes
it changes it to 30 minutes this allows
the election workers a little bit more
time to get this done and
this is not very controversial
um
and
it's a housekeeping bill really and i
i think
it's good
any further discussion on sb 364.
seeing none i'm going to ask our
substitute clerk for the day
representative hayward to call the role
representative mcdonald yes
representative prudhomme o'brien yes
representative sweeney yes
clark votes yes representation
yes
representative barry yes
representative moffat moffatt
yes
representative quailey yes
representative murder
yes
representative bone
i got it representative bergeron yes
representative telersky
yes
representative hawkin phillips
representative sandler
representative hamer yes
representative wilhelm yes
representative freitas
yes representative hamlet
yes
representative
madam chair yes
vote is 20-0 thank you very much without
objection that will go on the consent i
want to thank everybody for your
indulgence and my scheduling this
morning thank you very much to the
substitutes who came down this morning
um welcome to election law i think it's
how you think at the end of this morning
i don't know
um and with that we our business is
concluded we will be back together in
this room next week thank you very much
2 15. yeah
no we're back here next wednesday at
9 30 i think
10 am is that what the notice says
whatever the notice says
you